okay before we go ahead and start this
hearing
perhaps we ought to have the uh folks
that are standing in uh introduce
themselves why don't we start with you
represent Howard
hi I'm representative Heath Howard I
represent Stratford and Barrington uh
I've normally serving on the house uh
election law but today I'm here with you
thank you and represent Lane you've been
here before yes I'm a frequent flyer how
about a frequent flyer yeah
I'm also on the election law committee
and um thank you for having me back good
Hill
um I I'm a frequent flyer in education
since 2010.
okay so what we're going to do is we're
going to jump right into our hearings
here the first bill which we have up
this morning is uh the Constitutional
Amendment uh number seven that's the use
of money raised by taxation for
Education uh welcome representative
cordelli thank you Mr chairman uh
colleagues for the record Glenn cordelli
representing Tuftonboro Wolfeboro and
Ossipee and the Beautiful Lakes Region
um
in the 1800s the common schools concept
was started by horse man in
Massachusetts
and his thought was in order for there
to be a civil society there needed to be
civil and religious education for all
since our nation at that point was
primarily Protestant all the schools
would be no different in religion and
reading from Bibles were part of the
common school education
but problems arose in the mid-1800s with
the immigration of Catholics from
several countries including Ireland
these immigrants arrived here and found
the schools
being having students taught from a
Protestant Bible which was contrary to
their Concepts and this led to
discrimination and violence
it was in this period that then U.S
President
Ulysses S Grant gave a speech calling
for a constitutional amendment to forbid
States from providing public funds to
any school that taught sectarian AKA
Catholic tenants
James Blaine of Maine was the speaker of
the U.S House of Representatives and a
friend of Grant
Blaine envisioned himself to be the
successor as President Grant he
introduced a constitutional amendment
that provided for no State funds to go
to any original religious sect
the amendment passed the U.S house and
came Within
one vote of passing the Senate
but the anti-catholic movement did not
end there our state was not exempt from
that
hardly had the first Catholic parish
been established in Dover then there
were attempts made to burn it down in
both 1830 and 1831.
in the 1850s there were anti-catholic
incidents in Peterborough Newmarket
Manchester Dover Portsmouth in
Greenville attempts were made to burn
down Saint
Anne's in Manchester and its Convent in
both 1858 and 1859.
states began to adopt these many Blaine
amendments or no Aid blame amendments
after the failure of the U.S Amendment
uh
we added a Blaine Amendment which is
part two articles 83 in our Constitution
and it was clearly modeled after the U.S
uh attempted Amendment
why should this relic of anti-religious
period be removed from our constitution
two reasons first it's a relic of
anti-religious bigotry and a following
uh representative we'll discuss that in
more detail second is unconstitutional
and I'll bring up four recent U.S
Supreme Court decisions the first in
2002 was zelman versus Simmons Harris
this was in Ohio where the state had
assumed control of the Cleveland schools
and instituted a scholarship program
under that program tuition assistance
was provided to low-income students so
that they could attend a private or
public school of their choice including
religious schools a group of taxpayers
filed suit claiming that it violated The
Establishment Clause and went to the
United States Supreme Court and in a 5-4
decision the majority of ruled
for the plaintiffs and Justice rehnquist
stated the Ohio program permits such
individuals to exercise genuine Choice
among options for public and private
secular and religious the program is
therefore a program of true private
choice
in 2012 there was the Trinity Lutheran
case in Missouri and this was about a
state grants to provide playground
materials
the state said that the Trinity Lutheran
Church could not get a grant
for these playground materials for their
school playground because of their blame
Amendment
again went to the Supreme Court chief
justice Roberts stated but the exclusion
of Trinity Lutheran from a public
benefit for which it is otherwise
qualified solely because it is a church
is odious to our constitution all the
same and cannot stand
now even more recent
in 2002 there was the Espinoza versus
Montana Department of Revenue case
and the Supreme Court issued a landmark
decision for Mrs Espinoza and Montana
Montana families who wanted to use tax
credit scholarship money to go to
religious schools the Department of
Revenue Administration
ruled that because they had a blind
Amendment they could not do that
um
and I'll just point out that Blaine
amendment in Montana was quite similar
to our blame Amendment
a Supreme Court ruled for Ms Espinoza
and the other families and Justice Alito
wrote that if a state decides to fund
private education institutes it cannot
discriminate discriminate against
parents who choose to send their
children to religious schools
one more Supreme K court case
um was settled just this past June and
this was a school tuitioning case in
Maine
Maine began town tuitioning like we have
so that if children don't have a grade
level in their own town they can go to
a school Elsewhere based on town
tuitioning
but in 1981 Maine changed the law to
restrict tuition to non-sectarian
non-religious schools
in 2018 two families filed suit
that because they wanted to send their
kids to religious schools where it had
been allowed prior to
1981. the Carson versus Macon case went
to the Supreme Court and in the majority
opinion chief justice Roberts wrote as
noted a neutral benefit program in which
Public public funds float to religious
organizations through independent
choices of private benefit recipients
does not offend The Establishment Clause
and even more recent
um Maine has the oldest town tuitioning
program
in 2020 five families sued in Vermont
wanting to send their children to
religious schools
based on that Carson versus Macon Maine
decision the Vermont education secretary
sent a letter to all the state
superintendents this is just last
September
saying that
school districts and I quote may not
deny tuition payments to religious
approved Independent Schools that meet
educational quality standards under that
announcement
Vermont settled with the five families
and provided them funding for going to
religious schools
I believe that New Hampshire needs now
to repeal this unconstitutional
Amendment
we've heard four U.S Supreme Court
decisions that basically invalidate the
blame amendments
John Blaine of Maine is dead and the New
Hampshire Blaine Amendment needs to
deserve the same fate
there can be no excuse not to repeal
this remnant of anti-religious bigotry
the U.S Supreme Court has spoken and
it's now time for us to speak
by repealing this amendment and sending
it to the voters of New Hampshire
thank you thank you very much uh do you
have a copy of your testimony that I do
and I owe provides the clerk into the
record are there questions from the
committee for representative cordelli
yes representative Noble
Mr chair and thank you representative
cordelli for taking my question
if the blame Amendment were to remain in
our constitution someone could file suit
to block funds going to New Hampshire
um that is correct yeah um it's uh open
for additional lawsuits
um I don't think it would be very wise
based on the U.S Supreme Court decisions
um but if someone wants to do it I say
Bring It On
further questions
represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking the question
um nullification occurs when a state
decides it's simply going to ignore
federal law so given that the Supreme
Court has already ruled that this is an
unconstitutional law if we refuse to
remove this and repeal this could that
um I I wasn't going to go there but if
you think it is I'll
I'll accept your opinion of you
further questions
yes representative right
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative uh I'm looking at the the
section in the State Constitution and it
says the amendment was added a lot later
than the original Constitution so my
question is we we lasted a long time
without this is that correct
um uh yes the um Blaine amendment was
added to our constitution in 1877 and
I'll just note that when the voters
decided uh to add that to the
Constitution they also voted to remove
Provisions from our Constitution that
further questions from the committee
nothing thank you very much thank you uh
I'd like to recognize Representative Bob
Lin
good morning
thank you Mr chairman members of
committee um thank you for permitting me
to testify here I'm Bob Wynn I'm a state
representative from Windham and I appear
in support of uh cacr7
um I I you know I agree with uh I was
here for most of Representative
cordelli's testimony and I think I agree
with all of it in terms of he gave a
very thorough recitation of the
background of this
um and I it it seems to me as a
practical matter this amendment the the
language in the Constitution now that
the the that incorporates the Blaine
amendment is really uh it's no longer
effective I mean it's it would it could
not be enforced because it's blatantly
unconstitutional under the U.S
Constitution and there's no real reason
to keep it in the state constitution it
it does it does have the you know the
sort of Sting of of the religious
bigotry that it was based upon uh from
uh from the you know the the fear that
the other you know too many Southern
Europeans too many too many Irish
Catholics and Italian Catholics and
whatever
um are are uh are you know uh coming and
my my God they you know they if they
send their kids to school they might
that might uh into uh religious schools
they might uh uh you know that that will
further their education and my God they
might get elected to A legislature
sometime and what will my God how would
that happen if uh that would be so awful
if we didn't have only you know white
male Protestants uh uh running the
running the country and so they took
some action to uh to further that
um it seems to me that we've gotten way
beyond that now and that the sensible
thing to do would be to remove uh to
remove this from the Constitution and
that's that's really about about all I
all I have to say I'm happy to answer
any questions thank you very much
representative
and we actually follow through with the
amendment and deny somebody
um public funds for a religious
Institution
are we going to be given the various
court cases already are we going to be
facing a pretty stiff penalty
well you know I I
think the answer to that would be I get
I I it I suppose it depends I mean I I
and maybe it depends to some extent on
how creative some lawyer can be maybe
there are you know there are really
creative lawyers in Washington with some
interest group or other that could try
to say well you know the language of New
Hampshire's amendment is somehow not
covered uh by the earlier Supreme Court
decisions it seems to me that that would
be a real stretch to try to do that and
so I guess I would say I think your your
point is well taken that honestly it
there would I would think that somebody
that would bring a lawsuit
based upon the state constitution in
light of the U.S Supreme Court decisions
would face the real possibility that
they're going to be sanctioned for
bringing a frivolous lawsuit
um that would be my impression
representative thank you
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
being here
uh if you look at some of these uh U.S
uh Supreme Court decisions
uh in the Lutheran bill is basically
dealing with playgrounds
in Espinoza it was dealing with tax
credits and in this state we've heard in
this committee that tax credits really
aren't tax money as it would relate to
out of the uh education trust fund
in Maine it was a very narrow decision
that basically said in rural rural
school districts where there is no
school district or school for that child
going to a middle school or high school
that they could use public money to go
to religious schools so those are very
narrow kinds of decisions
I'm asking this particularly of because
of your background representative on the
Supreme Court
am I wrong in saying that as I I was
trying to find it in the Constitution
here but my reading of the Constitution
the original constitution of this state
has a provision in it that says no tax
money shall go for religious purposes
but not notwithstanding the blame
amendment I can contr
I can agree with the issue of the blame
Amendment but the original Constitution
doesn't it have a piece in there that
says no taxes no taxation money will go
to religious schools for religion I
don't know if it says religious schools
I thought it uh
um if you have the I know there I think
you're right that there is another
provision is the original constitution
in the original Constitution that does I
I'm not sure about the religious schools
part I don't think I thought it had
something to do with just more more
broadly religion I think I I think that
might be right thank you very much
further discussion yes representative
Howard
well uh thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question uh based on your
testimony do you believe that our state
education system is failing to educate
anyone other than white Protestants
do I believe that it is failing to
educate anyone other than white
Protestants now do you mean do I think
that there's some kind of uh
discrimination against no I do not I do
not if if you're asking is there some
you know is there somewhere in the state
where some School District or some
individual that's an official of a
school district is discriminating
against someone that's not white
possibly but if you're asking is there
some kind of you know systematic
discrimination against people that are
not white no I don't I don't think
that's true at all
represent Luna
thank you very much Mr chair and and
thanks for joining us um uh this morning
and bringing your uh your experience to
bear in this area
um I want to go to the the back of the
back page of um of
CR7 that that contains the the voter's
guide information and I want to direct
your attention down to the um the uh the
final sentence
um in the paragraph that begins on line
one at the present time okay and it goes
it reads the United States Supreme Court
has ruled that if any money raised by
taxation is granted to any private
school it would be unconstitutional to
exclude any school of a religious sector
denomination I was wondering if you
could speak to whether or not any money
raised by taxation is currently being
granted to a private school in New
Hampshire is any money raised by
taxation is being granted to a public
School in New Hampshire right well I
suppose uh if you if you're I mean if
you're referring to the education
Freedom accounts yeah I mean and
actually if we if we want to put the put
the efas aside okay um just for now so
that we're not mixing that into the
argument but just just looking at at um
you know obviously school districts
right you know have have taxing
Authority in New Hampshire so they're
raising public money do school districts
via their school boards which is the
governing body of a school district
um
um uh Grant any of those publicly raised
tax dollars to private schools you know
I'm not sure about that but it may be
are aren't there some
smaller districts where they where
there's not enough I thought I remember
all I know about this really is sort of
what I've read in the paper to be honest
but I thought that there were some
smaller districts where they didn't have
for so for one reason or another there
was not a public school available for
the student for students in the district
to go to and that at least in some
instance some of those children may have
gone to religious schools so I suppose
that you know pay for pay for it by the
state right right have you ever paid for
it by the district by the district so
follow up on that and what where I'm
where I'm going with this and let's just
take that as a generic scenario right
now that that small town a that does not
offer their own Public Schools or let me
say
um small school district a that does not
offer that does not run their own Public
Schools contracts with with a private
school to provide their their
constitutional requirement to educate
all the children in that in that
District does that does that private
school have to comply with our state's
requirements for public schools
that's an excellent question that I
don't Proclaim to have any expertise on
so I'm I'm not I'm not sure what the
answer to that would be I I guess
my requirement for special education my
services or accessibility or something
like that well I mean for example I I
assume that that that let's let's take
the example that we're just both talking
about I assume that if if the student
that we were talking about that the that
the uh the school district for one
reason or another couldn't educate in it
in its Public Schools or it didn't have
a public school whatever if that was a
special education student that was
disabled in some way
you know I would assume they could not
it would be it would not it would be a
violation of the of of the disabilities
the federal disability statute for this
school to send that person to a school
district to a school that could not
accommodate the the students disability
right that so so so in that case that
private school contractoring with with
small District a to provide Public
School uh to provide education for all
of its children
um is is providing the role as being the
public school
um for that school district and and has
to be compliant with with
um uh with our Public School laws in the
in the in the state so
so so the the where I'm where I'm going
we need yeah where I'm going with this
uh with that with that private school
that's under contract to provide
Education Service for all the children
in in small school district a
um be considered a private school that
um you know where where where you know
parents place their kids in private
schools all the time or would it be
considered in the role that they're
providing would it be considered to be a
public school that's an interesting one
I'm not sure I know the answer to that I
mean I I guess I would say that maybe
there's a difference in the situation of
where the school district as opposed to
the parents have determined that this is
the school where that person has to go
to right as opposed to the parents
making the choice maybe that maybe that
makes a difference in terms of what the
school you know the school's obligations
are I I'm just not sure about that I'd
want to think about it all right thank
you very much judge this is a point of
clarification under the tuition program
we have
a local board makes that decision to
approve the receiving school be it the
Montessori school or be it uh Newport
High School
and the locals district has
responsibility to ensure that the child
that's being tuitioned out receives an
opportunity for an adequate education it
may be through to a tuition School A and
B may not provide all those services but
the school districts living up to its
obligation by ensuring that the student
can go to school a uh we we see that
happening often in our tuition contracts
in this state
let's go on to the next question is
there another question sure represent
drying I I have to get up to HHS
oversight I just had one minute can I
can I say my piece Yeah well yeah you
know yes because I want to listen to him
but I I just said you want to listen to
the judge you know well not you know
what but you know what here you can I
here's what I I don't in any way want to
be disrespectful to this committee but
I'm subbing today in criminal justice
and they're and they're expecting me to
be over there too so uh uh I so I'm
sorry no no I I appreciate it I guess so
I guess what I would so you want to hold
up for another person or I mean I wonder
if I I wonder if you know I do you have
just any interest of time 30 seconds for
this sure yes absolutely what is the
blame amendment in our constitution
because it says that it was amended to
prohibit tax monies to schools of
religious things in 1877 so I assumed
that that section in 83 is the blade
Amendment right it's the one in section
1983 but as was pointed out before there
is another section and I don't remember
where but there is another section that
was in the original Constitution that
makes some reference to religion thank
you we're going to let that yeah thank
you very much absolutely and have fun in
the next committee thank you very much
so thank you Mr chair uh I'm
representative Jess Edwards representing
District 31 uh that's Chester Auburn
Candia and Deerfield and uh I'm I'm not
an attorney I'm somebody who's been
fascinated in this section of all around
blame amendments so I've been following
it uh as a as a constitutional
conservative and I have entered into a
number of conversations on Facebook and
in other forms and one of the things
that comes back to me
regularly when I talk about the removal
of overt religious discrimination from
our constitution is the the warning as
though I should be afraid of it that
this will open up
um kids going to Muslim schools madrasas
and as somebody who spent time in
Afghanistan training Muslims how to you
know fight and defend their Nation I I
needed to read a lot of cultural
background and I would say that to those
that may Harbor that concern that this
would open it up to madrasas as well I
I'm fine with that I think we're a
pluralistic nation that doesn't
discriminate on the basis of religion
and it would be perfectly acceptable for
us to be comfortable with parents
choosing the school of their choice so
so my only comment was if you're hearing
from your constituents that we need to
be afraid that if we get rid of this
that it'll open the door to madrasas I'd
say that's okay but that's my testimony
thank you very much representative are
there any quick questions for the
representative
um represent Damon you want to just
indicate the the part of the law that
was you know the Constitution thank you
Mr chair so the
original Constitution Constitution that
representative Miler was referencing
this part one article 6.
and it was written on June 2nd 1784 or
passed into law then
good represent us the reference
could you read that well man let's just
get the next person testify and then
we'll get that it's elsewhere in the
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee of my
um for the record I'm Katie paternal I
represent Carol District Six top number
and Wolfeboro and before I get started
on my actual testimony I have a copy of
part one article 6 from
um
the first New Hampshire constitution of
1792 and it said the people of this
state have a right to empower and do
hereby fully empower the legislature to
authorize from time to time the several
towns parishes bodies corporate or
religious societies within the state to
make adequate provision at their own
expense for the support and maintenance
of public Protestant teachers of piety
religion and morality
so
um I'm speaking today as a co-sponsor of
cacr7 if this bill wasn't an attempt to
amend the New Hampshire Constitution I
might consider it a housekeeping bill
the description of this bill is
misleading there's no fiscal note and
there's no request to actually fund
sectarian or religious schools
this bill is simply a request to right
or wrong a request to remove an
Amendment added out of bigotry and
hatred for Catholics back in the middle
of the 19th century it comes from a time
when the population of New Hampshire was
rapidly changing
immigration was exploding in incoming
Catholics were seen as a threat to the
then generally Protestant state in fact
in spite of this amendment Catholics
continued to work with the state for the
betterment betterment of Education
all New Hampshire Public Schools were
originally religious in nature because
they were created to provide the basis
for a religious life that to Protestants
required reading and understanding the
Bible and devotional texts many who
learn to read as children lost the skill
unless it was maintained for religious
reasons an initial problem with
sectarian schools was the debate over
which Bible to teach or if the Bible was
even actually read by Catholics
Catholics were also seen as having views
that were incompatible with the
individual Independence and personal
Authority that were the core of American
identity
there wasn't always animosity however in
1861 the city of Manchester actually
gave Catholics the use of a vacant
school which was known as the Park
Street School
it was controlled by the local school
board and salaries were even paid by the
board until 1868.
at that time the local press
printed an editorial that attempted to
prove that Catholic schools were
contrary to the Constitution and laws of
the state
one city in New Hampshire seems to have
been somewhat immune from the bigotry of
the time
non-catholics contributed as generously
as Catholics to the building of Saint
Joseph's Church a proof that the storm
of religious persecution which swept
over many places in the state never
reached Laconia
Catholic schools grew independently of
public schools until the United States
began to firmly americanize
their education and the use of English
became mandatory in Daily instruction so
a lot of our education laws were created
in order to make sure that we spoke a
unified language
the Catholic or parochial schools were
then recognized by the New Hampshire
State Board of Education
with the passing of the law of 1919
establishing education standards for the
state parochial schools began working
with the New Hampshire school board
to bring private schools in line with
public schools in fact the untiring
efforts of Bishop guertin in the 1920s
culminated in the most amicable
relations between public and parochial
school authorities
all school all schools public and
private grew so well in the period
following the educational reforms of
1919 that by 1955 to alleviate the
educational problems common to both
systems the New Hampshire legislature
has been asked to pass legislation
enabling private educational
institutions to obtain loans not funds
at a low rate of interest for expansion
and renovation of physical plants
without private parochial schools the
state would not have been able to
educate the growing number of students
at that time
in the words of Wilfred J Lessard a
member of the State Board of Education
from 1919 to 1932
no parochial school is a foreign school
or a school for foreigners it is an
American School in which the language of
the Constitution of the country and
state is the basic language for
instruction and administration while
retaining its own characteristics
for a while in a concert the various
instruments Take A Part in the rendition
of the same Melody
each musical instrument must be held and
played according to the rules which are
peculiar to it
so and the educational Melody of New
Hampshire the parochial schools shall
sound religious and patriotic notes and
always harmonious with the great task
which confronts us the betterment of all
the schools in New Hampshire
considering the role that Catholic and
Christian Schools play in educating this
of the State of New Hampshire and
considering that they are not recipients
of state tax dollars it is the duty of
the State of New Hampshire to amend our
constitution
by removing the bigoted line in article
83.
thank you
thank you are there any questions of
represent paranel represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair and thank you rep
better now
um I had hoped to get this question to
the judge but I believe you may be able
to answer it also
we had heard a pointed argument about
another portion of the New Hampshire
Constitution that would be cited to
prohibit uh Public Funding for Religious
Education
however
in 1961 the Supreme Court in torcasso
versus Watkins ruled secular humanism
has afforded religious protections as a
faith
faith-based our item
therefore
if we were to interpret this to say that
these public funds cannot be used to go
to a religious school could not the same
argument be made that funding public
secular schools falls under the same
paradigm
possibly but if we were to apply the
Constitution to the original purpose of
our public education we wouldn't be
funding public education at all thank
you
for the questions represent luno
thank you Mr chair and thank you very
much representative for for taking my
question
um so I want to sort of go to the uh to
what the what the intent is behind the
uh cacr7 and I was wondering if you
could talk um with us a little bit about
how the New Hampshire Constitution uh
how how it is right now the New
Hampshire Customs is preventing well you
know what is the I guess what is the New
Hampshire Constitution preventing from
happening today
that um that is the motivation for for
this um proposed Constitutional
asking about
um funding different schools and what
the state does to fund different schools
and whether or not I'm really getting
out what's what what's
being prevented from happening today
that that requires this change
to the Constitution there's actually
nothing in fact we've never funded these
schools they they grew independently
of the public schools they actually just
coordinated courses of study in order to
make sure that all of the students of
the state were educated in a similar
manner to become good citizens and a
prime example being that all of the
sectarian schools in the early 1900s
were being instructed constructed solely
in the English as the primary language
so what's the amendment trying to do
it's just trying to remove a bigoted
outdated statement it's happened nothing
just keeping things the same as they are
we don't fund non-public schools with
state tax dollars it's just removing a
bigoted purposeless statement that's why
I said it's like a housekeeping it's
just taking
it's just
not doesn't belong in the Constitution
it's a bigoted statement it doesn't
change anything we don't fund non-public
schools and if you look at the doe
website
Christian and Catholic schools are lit
or parochial schools are listed with in
the conglomeration of all non-public
schools none of them receive state
funding so it's not really changing
a bad line from the Constitution that
never should have been in there in the
per in the first place because the state
never had the intention of
funding these schools
thank you very much are there are there
well do you want further questions
okay thank you thank you very much
no but that's later on in a different
place
so with that I'm going to close this
hearing down I have no other cards in
front of us so uh cacr7 hearing is
closed
um we'll take five minutes and then
we're going to start executing some of
our bills we can't exact any bills until
10 30.
now that's when it shows up in the
calendar
is
yeah you would cross that name out and
foreign
turn on my mic here we're opening up the
executive session and uh the first bill
in executive session I'd like to take up
is a continuation of the bill which we
had discussed earlier but uh it was
hb170 the the way that tracked out for
everybody uh we had a motion of OTP
initially
then we had an amendment Prince
presented that Amendment also passed
with 19-1 then we voted on that and the
motion Was Defeated or not recommended
with a 1010 type vote and the next
motion which was popped up was itl and
that's where we remain right now with
that itl motion so what I'm going to do
is that I'm going to open up that itl we
we've had that motion made
and that motion was seconded I believe
it was seconded
then we are going to have a little
discussion right now on 170 and as
agreed with uh the the ranking uh
representative here we've got a little
bit of discussion on the possible uh uh
comments and suggestions presented by
representative leckis
um and then we will uh but remember
we're still on a motion of itl so in
order to
take up any action or anything that's
being offered to US during this
discussion the itl had been would have
to be taken back
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
recognize uh represent like us for
okay originally
um we had talked
there's already a motion on the table
there's already emotional okay this is a
continuation of an executive session
which we closed down right weeks ago
does everybody have the amendment
what's the number it's uh number zero
and the amendment came about because
originally we had
talked about just adding that
excellent uh line that says that the
requirement may be accommodated modified
or waived in accordance with a student's
individual with their IEP or 504 plan
and that was to the original bill which
only changed encouraged to require
so
um when it came back from OLS that's not
quite the way it was written and the
memorization part of multiplication
tables was not in there and we had
agreed
most of us had it we had agreed that we
were going to do the original plus that
line
so when it was noticed that it wasn't in
there I went and got this amendment but
what I didn't get unfortunately was the
um when it had to be done by
so this is this is what I got and it
basically
um leaves the bill as it was and adds
the accommodation section
okay so is there any further discussion
on that I that
position
okay so the emotion yes
representative
um thank you I don't know if it's a a
question or or
my wondering would this with this new
language
what does it actually do that the
federal and state law and special ed
doesn't already do
you know I don't understand the purpose
because you can already do this
that's all
okay so we have a motion on the table
um
uh for itl was there any inclination on
the part of those that made the itl to
withdraw the itl no so we're going to
take action on the itl motion
mayor clerk are you is there any further
discussion on the itl
ma'am clerk would you just got it
together okay great
all right so the motion to is itl uh
hb170 this is a bill dealing with
cursive handwriting and memorization of
multiplication tables
yeah
Vice chairman cordelli no
representative like us no
representative Ford no
representative Belcher no
representative dry no representative
McDonnell no representative Noble no
Representative pedernal no
representative Hill yeah
representative Miler yes
representative Howard
yes representative Lane yes
representative luno yes representative
Ellison yes representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes and chairman
Ladd no
10 years 10 Nays so we have no
recommendation uh on this bill uh who
will be writing on uh representative
representative cascadden
okay
in support of Ito
yes yes
um who who moved and seconded that we'll
get somebody thank you
s
moved it okay
okay
and Lucas will do the
the otpa would not be the amendment
that's right
okay
next bill which we have in front of us
is HB
394.
representative cordelli do you have a
motion
yes I would like to move that this bill
be retained
is there a second
I'll second that
representative
uh represent cordelli would you like to
speak to your motion
um thank you I I think that um
there are some uh interesting aspects uh
to this in terms of the chairmanship of
uh Co-op district and the
um idea of moving meetings between
locations
um I think it uh
could possibly use some more work
however and that's why I think it should
be retained
further discussion representative
analogy you made the second you have
anything yet is there any further
discussion on the motion to retain
represent Luna sure thanks thanks very
much for sure
um yeah I mean this this is a uh I I
just I you know I I think we heard
during last session that uh that there's
probably a lot of work that needs to be
done with respect to co-op um um school
districts and maybe this could be part
of that uh that work and and looking at
that but I think as it uh as it stands
here I don't think this is worth
retaining and uh and I I you know I
think it should be itl'd
yes representative thank you um on the
retained motion is that any priority I
just listen you know and IPL or this
take one at a time just modification
well he was indicating through his
discussion that he didn't see the Merit
in retaining and that to itl I I that's
okay but there's nothing no hierarchy
there's no no okay no thank you no thank
you chair thank you
is there a further discussion from the
yes representative McDonald thank you Mr
chair there are some concerns brought
forward in the hearing that this could
make meetings less successful to the
public if it was in a town that had the
Lesser population then people would have
to drive further the majority of people
and they'd be less likely for members of
the public to come to their school board
meetings
and it just seemed to be more difficult
for everyone so I see the Merit in
retaining the bill because it could work
on Cooperative school boards together
however this bill in particular
there was just a lot of testimony in the
contrary so I understand that an itl
motion might be in order
thank you
for the discussion
Madam clerk would you take the rule on
for a vote to retain Vice chairman
cordelli yes
representative leckis yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald no
representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative Hill
yes
representative Myler
representative Howard
no representative Lane no
Representative luno no
representative Ellison no representative
Woodcock no representative Hall no
representative Balboni no Representative
cascadden no representative Damon no and
rep chairman Ladd yes
all right the vote was nine years 11
days I recognize representative McDonald
for a motion
thank you Mr chair I move that this bill
representative McDonald do you like to
speak to your motion no thank you
we're just going to let the clerk catch
up here anyone
all right motion is itl
Vice chairman cordelli no
Representative lekkas no
representative Ford
no
representative Belcher no
representative dry no representative
McDonald yes representative Noble no
Representative pedernal no
representative Hill no representative
Miler yes representative Howard yes
representative Lane yes representative
luno yes representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes and chairman
Ladd no
the vote is 11 years nine Nays so this
does anyone want us to write the I'm a
Minority Report
okay
um
look to uh representative for Delhi to
granelli
yeah okay thank you yeah
discussion from the maker of the motion
nope
from the second
no further discussion
and clerk when you catch up we're ready
the motion is for 563 adoption SAU
Vice chairman cordelli yes
yes
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry I'm going
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
pedernal
representative Myler yes
oh yeah sorry my bad yes
representative Lane yes representative
luno yes representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman Ladd
yes all right 19 years one nay sir are
next bill which we have here is I'm
going to jump and go to 651
foreign
I went to 651 that's a contracts with
Transportation companies
I love to represent cordelli for a
motion
I like to move uh retain
is there a second to that
representative cordelli are you busy
writing
uh thank you okay
um
yeah I believe that there are now uh
several
companies interested in coming into New
Hampshire
um I think that there are discussions uh
going on in terms of uh the requirements
um in order to gain the
working relationship with the Department
of Motor Vehicles in terms of the
requirements for those companies and the
drivers so I would like to give
all involved more time to see what can
be worked out and therefore retain the
bill
for the discussion
did a represent Luna yeah thank you very
much Mr chair
um you know there we obviously I think
we all received substantial opposition
to this bill from um was it Department
of Safety uh department of insurance I
think was Department of Safety uh and uh
and and I think it raised a lot of a lot
of concerns but I would support the the
retaining the bill to see if those
concerns can be worked out as
representative cordelli has um uh has
articulated because there there may be
some opportunity uh where this
um where this may be a benefit uh I I
don't know that but I think pertaining
it would be a reasonable
reasonable result now thank you further
discussion
not seeing any uh Madam clerk the motion
is to retain uh 651.
chairman cordelli yes
representative Lucas yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal
yes representative Hill yes
representative Miler representative
Howard yes representative Lane yes
representative luno yes representative
Ellison yes representative Woodcock no
representative Hall yes
Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no
and chairman Ladd yes
16 years and four Nays okay the bill
next bill we're going to go into is 654.
that's uh dealing with the one year
uh thank you Mr chairman and um I would
call on the chairman for a motion yes
I'd like to recommend for 654 OTP
second
anyone
okay uh discussion
uh yes thank you uh I'd like to
does everybody have a copy of that
there are a few of that they were handed
out but I I have a few extras right up
here
here's three coming that way
and the remainders are going wait let's
take another one for the record
thanks
that was second by represent Ford
what
okay I'd like to go ahead and discuss
this amendment the amendment makes a a
change uh which I'll speak to in a
second uh for those that we have uh here
with us that are not here earlier to
hear any of the presentation on the
hearing 654 was the one bill that was
given the uh the right to be entered
late after the filing date
and it's a bill that's part of where
we're going how we're trying to deal
with teacher shortage in our state this
is just one small option available to
help that uh sort this whole issue out
where we're short with science teacher
science math teachers technology special
education
what this bill does is that we have on
the books right now 189 39b which is
part of legislation states that a
one-year Certificate of Eligibility can
be provided by the local superintendent
based upon criterial CN lines 12 through
14 in this bill those are the three
areas which are in effect currently
and this bill does nothing that changed
that what this change does though it
changes the definition well it says
where it's a teaching credential license
or other teaching certificate and
educator credential and it's by changing
teacher to educator we're allowing all
those that are working within the school
district the opportunity to the
superintendents to find a a person in
the area of Technology that's perhaps
certified but not necessarily called a
teacher or a librarian media specialist
Etc
what this does and this bill has been
supported widely by folks in the field
we encourage everybody to have
certification and meet the standards we
have for certification
and we have those that can come in based
upon those Criterion lines 12 through 14
and that have a bachelor's degree in
experience or education relevant to that
particular job and they pass the
criminal background check
and uh they're seen as a person that can
walk in and do the job by the
superintendent hiring and and and and
and and and and they oftentimes are
given that one-year ticket
which they may come in in November so
that ticket's good November to November
or whatever month it may be and we're
finding that during this time there's
some that would like to continue on and
and are working towards their
certification but are unable to do it in
that one short period of one year
and what this does is it allows this to
continue for two years and this is very
apropos for this time when we have a
teacher shortage so what this basically
does the bill changed it's the word
teaching to educator I'll also note that
there has been question in the past
whether the person that's taking this
responsibility is bound by the
professional code of conduct
and ethics yes they are and this
definitely clarifies that position it's
in law here even though according to
director Appleby they already had this
responsibility to file the code but this
just ensures it so
um this is why I put this forward as an
effort to try to help us during this
time when we see there is a need to
sometimes extend this it's also noted in
the bill that
we extend for one year but the year
you're extending to has to be a budding
that first year it can't be you have one
year you skip two years you want to come
back and finish the other no they have
to be consecutive abutting years so I
won't discuss any further I hope that
explains for those that are new to the
committee
uh further discussion representative
cascadden thank you I would encourage
everyone to approve the um to vote in
the positive for OTP
what this also does is allow for say a
candidate that works in the school
district as a paraprofessional or
teacher aide or an interventionist
who has potential and never had the
opportunity to go to go away to college
for four years but has some education
base and then must take a certain number
of courses to get certified and I have
to pay for that out of pocket
excuse me
um so this allows them that excuse me
that extra year
um to be able to get through to the
I'm representative Ford
thank you thank you Mr chair
um
I would like also to note that there are
several programs underway already
attempting to advance Paris and others
to move into a teacher preparation uh
program and they're organized proposals
including one funded with a grant from
the Department of Labor to provide
health care for these people because
they often cannot afford to go to school
to become fully certified as a teacher
because they can't give up their health
care for their families and so they now
can get to with some help from others
get grants to provide health care and
other necessary supports so I would
further discussion
scene none Madam clerk um I think we're
vice vice chairman cordelli yes
representative Lucas yes representative
Ford yes representative felcher yes
representative try yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative Hill yes representative
Myler yes representative Howard yes
representative Lane yes representative
luno yes representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes and chairman
no Nays
is there of further motion uh chairman
lad yes I'd like to recommend otpa on HP
654. second by representative miler uh
myself making a motion and represent
Myler and this is otpa yes okay yes
any discussion from anyone else
see none I think ready for the uh
final roll call
motion is ought to pass with Amendment
Vice chairman cardelli yes
representative legis yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative Hill yes representative
Myler yeah representative Howard yes
representative Lane yes representative
luno yes representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes and chairman
yeah so we'll place that one on consent
thank you very much representative
cradelli and they're going to be a lot
of happy uh superintendents out there
today on this one and we want to thank
uh director Appleby or doe for helping
us out with this bill
okay uh we're scheduled to start the
next hearing at 11 o'clock and we're
right at 11 o'clock so we have one and I
want to congratulate this committee buy
bills we just knocked off during the in
the half hour's time in exact session
it's remarkable for this group
okay all righty so now we're ready for
this one I just the motion clear
amendment that was yours yeah you second
did it
um
that was all about that okay that was
am I what should I just do this first
things
you seconded on to mass Amendment and
then we hear a lot to ask and then
you'll offered the amendment yeah yeah
uh there's no there isn't I just didn't
uh
thank you
for recommending actually elements so
we'll get it I just wanted to get that
okay thank you the next bill which we
have on the docket here today to be
heard is HP 515 this is relative to
education Freedom accounts
represent cordelli
uh thank you Mr chairman uh for the
record uh Glenn cordelli representing
Tuftonboro we'll throw and Ossipee and
the Beautiful Lakes Region and uh HB 515
um is an attempt to clarify some things
in statute
um
part of which
um were discussed during the rule making
process
as well as some
legislation that is passed since uh the
EFA programs were implemented
um I just wanted to highlight uh where
those changes are if I might
um on the first page on line two
um we added under the age of 22 for
eligible students to accommodate the
special needs children who now can get
Services until that age
on lines 11 and 12 we clarified that
there can be multiple
scholarship organizations
contracted to provide scholarships that
was not really clear in the current
statute
we added on line 14 the references to
current rsas
related to the
um
town tuitioning at our payment for
tuitions at a private school not Town
tuition excuse me
lines 18 and 19
uh wanted to clarify that um if uh an
EFA student was attending
a public school and taking classes there
that that would be uh paid for from
their uh EFA account and that the
department would not provide any
adequacy uh Grant or payment to that
school for those uh activities for the
EFA student
over to page two
on on lines 18 through 20.
we further uh clarified that a letter
from the teacher who was doing a review
of the portfolio as one of the options
for accountability for the the EFA
student that there would be a letter
that was provided to the scholarship
organization and then the scholarship
organization would make aggregate data
available to the department on student
aggregate data so that student privacy
is maintained as well as the privacy of
the evaluator
um we wanted to clarify that
um
an EFA student who enrolled full-time in
a different education option under the
compulsory Edge
attendance laws
would
have to withdraw from the EFA program
they couldn't be in multiple
compulsory attendance categories at the
same time
on line 28
um
we added intentional and substantial
has had been in our original
EFA language on the house side
on line 30 this has been discussed on
multiple occasions
that scholarship
organization shall refer suspected cases
it had been May in the statute and I
think everyone was in agreement that it
should be shall and that the department
um and then on the final change I
believe is on line 35
um where the current law had said the
department shall adopt rules but it's
really the State Board of Education that
adopts rules so this is uh primarily
housekeeping I believe
um and trying to make sure that uh
statute and rules are uh in sync
and that's really the intent of this
bill
thank you very much are there questions
representative Miley
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
bringing this to our attention this is I
qualify this is
one of the guard rails that you're
talking about as far as making sure that
there are some
rules here and this is good
two questions
uh how how do you perceive
is there multiple scholarship
organizations
how might that how's that going to be
administered I mean it's easier if you
have just one extended so that's my
first question
the second question is you did not
mention on line 28 of the first page
or you added an intentional and
substantial so if you could
um talk about what that means as far as
intentional and also the multiple thank
you
thank you
um
remind me of the first one again it's
kind of like the multiple organizations
thank you
yeah
um
right now we only have basically the one
scholarship organization approved by the
Department of Revenue Administration but
I think all was
under the tax credit scholarship program
which started out
establishing a non-profit approved by
the Department of Revenue Administration
to administer the tax credit scholarship
fund that there was also always the
intention that there could be multiple
and in in fact there I think there is a
second but it is managed by the
children's scholarship fund also
um so I think the intention was that any
scholarship organization
approved by a dra under RSA 77g could
also
um
provide for the EFA accounts and so I
think it would be the option of the
parent as to which company that they
wanted to work with and I know in
talking with the Department
that for the initial implementation
there was really only one non-profit
approved by dra they went with the sole
source contract for that but the
intention has been to do a an RFP in the
future for
as you pointed out in line 29 on the
first page and also 28 on the second
page
um
in our
there were two
um EFA bills there was this uh house and
a Senate Bill the house bill
um included the words intentional and
substantial the Senate bill which got
um now put into law included just
substantial
um I think that we wanted to include
intentional in there so that
um it was both uh not a mistake on the
part of an invertent mistake a provision
let's say of a receipt
um for uh reimbursement to the
scholarship fund that had to be
something intentional that they were
trying to misuse funds
um their
examples of uh we certainly want to
provide for uh uh making sure that there
is no misuse of funds but we want to
make sure that it's intentional misuse
of funds not just the mistake and
receipt that's being submitted
inadvertently as a maybe a package of
receipts to the scholarship fund for
reimbursement it could be for for
instance
a set of books or set a new second set
of curriculum for instance
um and it it could be
several sets of curriculum for instance
but only one set of curriculum for the
EFA student and another set of
curriculum for another student in the
household I know for example just a
simple example the scholarship fund has
denied
book purchases because they looked up
the book and it was not age appropriate
for the student who was recipient of the
EFA account but age-appropriate maybe
for another child in the household
so we want to make sure that this is
something that is an intentional act on
the part of the parent and not an
inadvertent Act
thank you further questions
representative McDonald thank you Mr
chair thank you Mr Vice chair for taking
my question I'm looking at line two on
the first page this says under the age
of 22. I'm curious as to why it's worded
that way when there's other bills before
us to say 21 inclusive just because to
keep it in line with federal statute I
know there's no technical change just
the wording I guess was it an oversight
um
I I think that
there are several places as you point
out where it says 21 inclusive I think
there was one place where it did say
under 20. age 22
um and so we just went with age uh
um 22 in this instance
um but uh I think I'd be fine with
either at this point all right thank you
yes representative Hall thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
is there an amount of money that
identified that matches with substantial
what is substantial you know and also
obviously what is intentional but
substantial is there a dollar amount uh
there is no dollar amount
um I I think that uh
um
various places in statute we use the
term substantial and so it's uh left for
some uh discretion in that regard
um but uh also if if we set a dollar
amount right now
um you know five years now five years
from now
um you know we could have a different uh
opinion on what substantial is so I
think uh just for
um uh
for the sake of
future
legislation and for
some discretion being exercised for
instance my book example I don't think
that that would be a substantial but uh
maybe a a playground set
for a child with special needs
um
versus a playground set for other child
in the household uh you know that might
be looked at it substantial
okay thank you further question
represent Luna
thank you very much Mr chair and um and
and thanks for bringing this in I think
there's some some interesting pieces of
this for sure as representative Miler
um but I want to sort of focus on on
page one
um uh towards the middle lines a line 16
through
19. so basically section four and uh
and you know it's hard to it's hard to
read section four when you don't sort of
see it
um as part of all of 194 F and uh
and where particularly you've got in the
the new language the department shall
make no State out of fee Grant payment
to the school for curricular activities
and programs for the EFA student and I
understand your your um your testimony
when you said this is for a student who
can take you know they're they're
spending up to uh well no no this is
actually contracted services so this
isn't this is this is not a public
school where a student is enrolled up to
50 percent
as a part-time student is that correct
uh correct there are any classes that
this EFA student signs up for a science
lab or whatnot at their local
um public school or charter school or
any any public school or Charter School
correct so this is not necessarily their
resident School District this could be
somewhere else and um right except for
full time okay that would be a step I
know this is sort of discussion
um but but would would the school that
is contracted for the public the
district Public School contracted for
under Section d in part four would they
also be required to provide
um special education services for uh for
a student no they would not be okay
thank you are there further further
thank you um I have a couple questions
um one I'm looking at lines 10 11 and 12
to describe
the opportunity the opening for multiple
scholarships would you consider changing
that area to having the New Hampshire
Department of Education oversee the
education Freedom accounts
no okay I think that's a separate piece
of legislation that we're dealing with
it is yes I just wanted to check that
and um one more question is on page two
lines seven eight nine and ten
um the areas of discipline
that must be provided is it the intent
that this would satisfy the competencies
or credits for earning a high school
diploma
um
uh no it did
um basically
um I think this section of 194 f
um just
states that child who gets an EFA
account
should receive education in these areas
I think these areas already spelled out
in other sections of statutes for public
school students so I think that this is
trying to be consistent with what our
children should know whether they are in
a public school or getting education via
an EFA account okay thank you I
I do have one more I just thought of
something
go ahead it's quick all right so going
back to the line on um
the representative aluminum was just
talking about that talks about programs
it would not fund oh curricular
activities and programs so line 19 so it
made me think of
programs
but yet there's some retail
providers
that EFA recipients can use for programs
so would that negate that list of
providers that are on the approved list
such as I don't know art lessons music
lessons uh Judo whatever program or
right I don't believe so I think that
this is specific for
um
um those areas in which the department
would provide if funds were available
the adequacy grant of what is it 0.15 I
think for taking a course at a public
school for instance it's targeted for
that area just to make sure that
um the EFA student is paying for those
and so I I got a question for you so
that and trying to stay on that topic we
know that a homeschooler can come in and
take a course in a school and the school
gets 0.15 right of a student in
reimbursement costs if money is
available
um so what are are you trying to this to
say that if an EFA student comes in they
got to use their EFA Monies to pay for
that course that they're taking exactly
I want to raise a favorite question that
representative Ladd usually asked and
that is if I have a daughter who is an
EFA program
and she is an outstanding softball
player
and she wants to travel to two districts
Beyond her resident
to participate in the championship
program of that school
and there happens to be a fee a a sports
fee to participate
this would then cover this would mean
that the EFA account would pay for that
fee to participate in that outstanding
yes right
um I'd have to go back and look at the
uh the full language in in 194 f
um but I think it's uh primarily
intended
um as with the home school students that
it would be their their local school
um I don't I don't know if there's
anything in current statute for
homeschoolers or for EFA students or
anyone to say it has to be it can't be
you know two two districts over or it
has to be your local let me cut in here
a little bit because we're now getting
an nhia
and uh you have to be a resident in that
District if not we're going to have
Semi-Pro teams all over the place here
and that's direction we don't want to go
so I think that's on the same page as
you're coming from as well
reps
yeah thank you thank you Mr chair and
thanks again representing Cordell I'm
still stuck on um on section four uh
because it and I don't know if this is a
scenario that would ever develop but um
but if if a student is is a resident of
District a and then uh and then leaves
um what's what would be the term uh
unenrolls as a full-time student in
District a establishes an EFA
goes back to District a for 50 percent
could they use
either their their EFA
to
to pay for additional classes beyond
their 50 enrollment in into District a
and would they be entitled to District a
diploma at some point down the road and
would District a have received any
adequacy grants from the state and what
responsibilities would District a have
for any special needs of that student
given you've got a hybrid situation here
where District a is is obligated to
serve as their public school for up to
50 percent and then is essentially
serving as a private placement for the
rest of the 50 percent
uh thank you
um
if
um I think elsewhere in statute it
defines that um
full-time is greater than 50 percent
um if they're going for part-time
um taking a couple of classes this
semester a couple of classes next
semester
um they have to pay for that there's no
and that's what the intent here is in
lines 18 and 19 to make sure the
department isn't paying for those
classes it's all coming out of the EFA
students account
um so that they can't mix and match and
have you know say I'm a part-time EFA
and part-time uh ADM student
um to get State reimbursement for the
other half it's it's one or that one or
the other they're they're either
part-time EFA student or they're
enrolling full-time back in their
resident District so I'm going to follow
up on that so where do what what would
prevent that from from happening I I
think that the earlier definition of
full-time student is greater than 50 I
think that that would
um so let's say they're 49. 49 I mean
this is just a I think an interesting
it's it's not I'm not ongoing dialogue
no I understand let's keep it the
questions I I mean I think you
understand what I'm what I'm what I'm
what I'm what I'm going after here and
what do what do we have any um is there
somebody from the Department that might
be able to explain what what the
resident District's obligation is to uh
to a student
um that may also have an EFA the
resident district has nothing to do with
an EFA because it's a step separate
compulsory attendance area that we have
established in law right so they can pay
for the courses but they're never going
to be an enrolled student in that school
so that they're not going to get a
diploma they're going to have to take
the high set or something else if they
want to get a high school graduation uh
diploma
uh
so
represent cascadden
thank you Mr chair
um representative I'm having a difficult
time trying to distinguish
programs because in my mind I'm not sure
if you're thinking of after-school clubs
but again on the service providers for
efas that is approved by the state
there's a number of Summer education
programs specialized education programs
and at least uh 35 virtual programs
so your bill in this line would
eliminate all that if I understand the
term of programs because they vary from
you know a house home schooling program
to a play date to a I mean a very very
gymnastics and whatnot religion
but how how do you interpret programs in
your language because I I'm trying to
separate that the two
um
I I think curricular activities and
programs is already in the statute and
so I just it was repeated
um in lines 18 and 19.
um because it's already in in statute on
line 18.
um in terms of individual classes and
curricular activities and programs
programs I think we've heard discussions
in the past that if EFA student wanted
to take part in a summer program for
instance that that would be and there
was a fee for it that that would be paid
okay and this does not negate Apparent
from
participating in all of these programs
well I do not believe so okay
there's certainly it's hard to
understand thank you Mr chair thank you
Mr Price here
um I will apologize in advance I spent
42 years as a lawyer so my my questions
are around the intentional piece the
intentional and substantial misuse
because intent is a really hard thing to
prove even in court
so you have
is and also you could have well that's
one question so how do you intend how
what's guidance or what you're asking an
organization a non-profit organization
to make that determination and
um it's a really hard Concept in in the
court to prove so how do you
it's it's really hard to prove right uh
you probably don't want to spend any
time as a lawyer most people have them
uh the term in intentional and
substantial
um I think has been recommended To Us by
lawyers and is uh similar terminology
that is used in
um many of the states that have uh Esa
education savings account types and
programs
um
you know I'll leave the the arguing
between lawyers
um to others on on the mean of
intentional
could I have a follow -up please yes you
may so
what would happen because you could have
an unintentional substantial abuse
those will never get reported under this
uh
an unintentional substantial probably
but I'm sure
um
there's a very
um close working relationship between
the current scholarship fund and any
future scholarship fund I believe
working with the Department because of
the process that's involved and I know
that the department is also trying to
hire as provided for in-law an EFA
administrator to constantly work with
the scholarship fund so I'm sure that
there would be
[Music]
discussions between the organizations if
anything came up um where there was a
substantial misuse of funds and a
yes representative Woodcock then
represent like us
thank you chairman
um
I'm not trying to be redundant because
I've actually written it down where it's
not these two things but I'm going back
to the the uh question 20 line 28 part
two is my initial question is was
representative Lanes
um
why would we why would we want
intentional there if we want the
scholarship organization to fall through
in substantial misuse
well it seems to me if you don't have if
I if I read it right I think that's what
she was trying to say or you said you
have to have both ingredients both
ingredients to be forwarded yes
um uh I'll just
um refer back also to
um all the discussions with the
administrative rules
um and gel car and that whole process
and um uh it seems to me in my reading
of what went on with the development of
the rules
um that uh there was discussion
um about uh the possible need for
intentional
um by uh some of the
lawyers involved working with
representative Lucas do you have a
follow-up question I I do and that the
answer confused is I was trying to
process it um the other question why I'm
trying to see everything burning up over
there like I'm killing it over here
thank you rather than what I'm sorry
about my car that you made fun of in the
last exact session
um
also Barb earlier and I'd written it
down so I don't think I'm trying to
cheat on somebody else's work
um the doe uh bill they just went
through the house
uh was talking about doe takeover
administration of the EFA accounts uh my
question is a lot of the language that's
relative here uh to scholarship
organizations but that can be negated if
the doe continues the process of taking
if uh if the doe takes over the
operation of the program is that your
question right
um I think that there would have to be a
lot of the statute Rewritten but um you
know that's another piece of legislation
that has already gone through
no no no I don't think I don't think we
voted on that okay yeah thank you thank
them both
thank you chairman you're welcome uh
reps and leckis
yes I was wondering
um the report that the
scholarship organization has to give to
the doe is very involved and complex and
has all kinds of information that's not
in this other report and there will be
multiple scholarship organizations
potentially
I'm wondering why you decided to have
the scholarship organization report to
the legislature rather and Etc rather
than the doe report to
have the scholarship organization report
to the legislature
but you you I forget what letter that
was that what line that was on at this
point I've looked at so many things
um the reporting
to the legislature and all you know the
Senate all of the you know I was
wondering why you have them report
rather than the doe report since the doe
already has from the scholarship
organization a much greater report
um
yeah I I had neglected to look at page
three
um I'm not sure that's where you're
looking but page three actually is our
new Provisions that are being required
um of the scholarship organization right
um
and thank you for uh reminding me of
those
um now there are several new reports
um that had been left out of the current
Statute in terms of annual reports from
the scholarship organization
um and uh
also a survey of parents and both of
these
um mimic what's required of the
scholarship organization under the tax
okay thank you
further questions representative um
Balboni well thank you Mr chair and
thank you representative for taking my
question
um I'm just going to go a little bit
different angle here on
sorry
on page two uh line 17
through 21 referring to the assessment
piece and the portfolio you've added in
with a letter from the teacher should be
provided to the scholarship organization
uh my question was refers to um it just
States very generally what the students
education progress and then it states
that uh that there will be aggregate
data made available I'm kind of curious
about the aggregate data would look like
because it's just a letter I mean is
there a template I mean what kind of
information would that
teacher be assessing and to go along
with that how do you know or who makes
the determination at all whether the
adequate progress has been made
well I think the termination of adequate
progress
um ultimately is the responsibility of
the parent
would be my response to that that
portion
um uh I I think that
um
one we we don't want
these are EFA students
um and I think we want to
provide for their their privacy there
could be multiple children in the
household it could be just one who's
receiving an EFA so we need to protect
their privacy
um
but also to make sure that the profile
has excuse me yeah the the profile
um section c on line 13 that the profile
has been uh done and has been reviewed
um that's the reason for the letter
going to the scholarship organization
follow-up yes please
um so this information just goes to the
scholarship organization again I'm just
still trying to understand uh
and it would be sent to the Department
the Department of Education right yes
okay yeah yeah
um department is um used um I think a
department is defined as the Department
of Education in the in the chapter
further questions of Representative
Cardell yes representative luno
thank you very much Mr chair and and I
know this is turning into a discussion
on on these questions but I'm still
stuck on section four and I'll try to
keep it to um to a question but um where
where the department where the the new
language on lines 18 and 19 say
basically the department shall not make
a state adequacy Grant payment to the
school so talk referring to the district
public school and um
and I'm I'm concerned how that reads up
um which which are the the rules that um
that are directed to the education
Freedom account program and it says a
child with a disability participating in
an EFA program and enrolled in a public
school Under RSA 194 F colon 2 Roman 2D
which is exactly what's being amended on
line 16.
is entitled uh to a um uh a free and
appropriate public education so I
believe that means special education
services and it goes on to say the
school district in which the child with
a disability participating in the EFA
program enrolled a public school Under
194 F2 Roman 2D resides is responsible
for the provision of of those special
education services so I'm wondering if
if lines 18 and 19 are now further
depriving their
um the resident school district and or
the the school district that is
providing these the contracted services
um I don't think so there there is
another uh section in 194 uh specific to
special education and we also have
um legislation
um about that and then notification that
has to be made to parents when they sign
up for an EFA about their options
um under idea
um and I think that that will be
um clarified with that legislation but
also in terms of
um this is this section was really
targeted at the curricular activities
um be it any one of the schools that
would normally receive
or could receive uh state adequacy
grants
if a special needs student
um
does enroll
in a public school they can enroll in a
out of District public school full-time
and pay for it with their EFA account
um and in those circumstances the
residence School District would be
responsible
um and and but that we'll get in I think
we'll get into that more with that other
piece of legislation because I I do have
some information regarding that but
yeah just to follow up sure is that
another piece of legislation I thought
we were done our hearings today
um so is this somewhere else or coming
in from somewhere
um I guess we had the hearing on that
piece it was a
um representative Tanner's uh
legislation uh next to me uh might have
been representative Cornell's
legislation no I remember that but no
I'm talking about uh I'm talking about
specific with respect to the the duty of
the resident School District to pay be
pay for right I I think that that I
think that needs to be clarified
um as part of that legislation
um and I'm
um looking at a possible amendment to
bring forward
um also uh at the exact session to try
and help clarify that so there does
appear to follow so there does appear to
be an inconsistency between statute and
rule in this area
I I gotta I'd have to go back and look
at the rule I'm sorry yeah thank you
very much representative cascadden thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question
um so historically if I was a
participating agent for homeschool
families they registered in the 2000 the
law and then you had to follow up
annually to get a progress and whatnot
or to assist I'm sorry I'm not sure what
you meant by agent I didn't understand
that
um well when when a family
wishes to homeschool they must notify a
participating agency which is normally
more often than not I believe that the
school's superintendent but it also
could be
you know what somebody else right could
be or just a letter to the Department of
Education
but for the most part I mean I managed
all those cases and then the 2000
legislation came down that they did not
need to provide any accountability in
the law that you had to annually provide
updates went away so once someone you
know said they were going to homeschool
that was the last that you may hear in
some cases not all because there are
there's some wonderful homeschool
families that I've I've worked with but
looking at lying uh well page two
17 18 19 and 20 where a letter would be
submitted on an annual basis
for student progress
do you do you believe that this would
now change for homeschool parents to
have an accountability no when they
don't no this is strictly within the 194
chapter for EFA okay program but I think
all along in talking to when we first
put the program in place we recognized
everyone recognized that homeschooling
was different
than an EFA student homeschooling and
that's why there are separate compulsory
attendance categories now for the two
okay and that's why some homeschool
parents
um elect not to
take an EFA accounts because they don't
want to
um
get involved with the government shall
we say
okay all right this is defined in the
compulsory attendances four categories
we're talking about private school
public school efas and homeschooling and
they're separate and apart from each
other
uh further questions from the committee
not seeing you're off the hook 45
minutes later
thank you I just had a wonderful time oh
but you did
okay so
um
the next hearing we have scheduled is
scheduled for
um 12 45.
so yeah we're closing this hearing yeah
this hearing is closed
and the next one is scheduled for 12 45
that's about an hour from now so what we
can do is we can take that hour lunch
break right now where everybody has that
time available to them and we'll come
yeah
yeah I got it um we're gonna have to use
every day so I'm going to start out with
the Monday the reason for that is that
from the 6th through half day on the
16th there could be as many as four
session days thrown in there so you
subtract that out of the nine eight and
a half eight quick Interruption could we
exact 632 right now
if we're all on the same page Ito
see I gotta find out where we are no we
did want IPL on this bill but we wanted
to retain on 394. I think they're
they're looking to have some kind of
um
foreign
want it from anybody
excuse me representative are you are you
presenting we need a pink card
um
we have one you know we have one I was
calling you did you want to try and do
that okay is he here Greg is here yes
but Allison's out
so right after this bill we will exec
and then those that because we have two
okay
I don't think he's going to take too
long no I know okay we're going to go
ahead with the next hearing that's
hb181 181
this is an act establishing a committee
to study school meal programs in New
Hampshire's public schools and
non-sectarian schools that accept public
so I am a leader I'm representative
Timothy Horgan for Stratford County
District 10 which is now the uh just the
town of Durham
and this bill looks pretty familiar we
it's been uh well we actually passed it
uh
last session and a committee met chaired
by uh
Sue Newman who sadly no longer remember
this house um
but but she's just taking a little uh
still very much around it's not bad
she's just uh doing other things and um
so that committee I think was fairly
successful and they learned a lot from
it and I don't know
uh probably probably won't be that
successful it might be like uh it may
not it made a lot to cover as much
ground as it did when Reverend Newman
was was uh running up I think it's still
uh a good idea still valid enough so I
would uh I presented this bill to you so
you're uh
free to either uh
so I recommend that you pass it even if
even if it's not quite as extensive as
what uh president Newman uh Newman did
it would still be a worthwhile exercise
because there was a lot of uh
interested in expanding and
restructuring uh School Meal programs
especially uh
especially since during the pandemic
years what rep honorable Sue Mullen
Mullen did I say Newman yes yes it's
Newman I humbly apologize especially
since
yeah she's very much in here yes mullet
Newman
thank you for correcting that I should
have should have written my testimony in
advance then but anyway Reverend Sue
Mullen chaired it remnants who knew what
I think also participated in it so
that's um
and especially especially of Interest
since during the pandemic uh in both
schools here in New Hampshire all the
students got free meals and that was a
very popular uh
that's a very popular program that's
obviously made possible just concerning
things we're doing lots of unusual
things during the pandemic and the
funding was available but um
it's still like a yeah I think there's I
think we're the importance of school
nutrition is uh being recognized
more more and more this committee would
be able to look uh look into a more
Innovative and better ways to uh to
reduce school school hunger to meet the
nutritional needs of all students and I
apologize for representative mother and
representative Newman may be watching on
YouTube for all I knows so
yes I'll be in trouble next time I see
her but she'll be nice about it so
that's uh so I apologize for apologize
for mixing up the names but uh I still
think it's a good bill and uh advise you
to pass it thank you looks like there's
a question thank you very much are there
any questions of Representative Horrigan
representative cardelli
uh thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
representative
um the previous uh committee that you
um mentioned
um was just last term I believe what new
information do you expect
this committee to come up with since
it's the previous one was so recent well
there's always new things to be found
out I know like when we had uh the bill
of this committee
I learned that there were more schools
and I thought that weren't part of this
school lunch program or that there'd be
startup costs and uh so that probably
needs to be a
that that's something that could be
clarified how much those startup costs
for and how to how to pay for them
um and there's just probably this is a
uh is it so they didn't they did a lot
of work I don't think they exhausted the
topic for all time or even for a few
years so a fan of they can't think of
anything either talk about they're
always free to issue a very very brief
report
um and send it to us in November before
we can extended until next year thanks
representative
thank you thank you for taking my
question I was on that committee yes I
remember thank you
and uh yes we did quite an extensive
study and the committee report at the
end was that the recommendation was not
to have a further study committee
because it was a study committee to
study a study committee yes and we
decided we were not going there was no
need for further study because we'd
already done it but out of it many of
the bills that we've seen and heard and
even voted on already this year came out
of that study committee
curious as to why we need to do it again
when we've learned a lot in that and the
bills and
well I just it's uh my co-spots and I
was just about there was a need to that
that at least give you considering
whether you wanted to like study some
more issues because I think there are
still a few issues left even though like
everything you said is like 125 correct
so
the committee did you and the rest of
you ready worked very hard and covered a
lot of ground is extremely valuable
exercise so
any further questions
do we have any other pink cards not see
any we'll close this hearing
corruption
where are you guys in that bill
y
okay we're going to take a five minute
foreign
one this is establishing a committee to
study school meal programs in New
Hampshire Public Schools and
non-secondary schools that accept public
funds
uh need a motion
yes
I move itl second okay we have a motion
made by representative leckis and second
by representative Myler itl
on 181.
any discussion from anybody on that
maker yes
as I said
uh during the questioning we studied
this extensively and what we decided was
our recommendation was no more study
committee thank you so that's it
representative Myler
would you like any discussion
any further discussion
Madam clerk would you please call the
roll
motion is itl
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leckis yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative Hill yes representative
Miler yes representative Howard yes
representative Lane yes representative
luno yes representative Ellison
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes and chairman
Ladd yes
okay we have one last bill we're going
to do very quickly as well and that will
allow our subs to hit the highway if
they want to appreciate represent Howard
and represent Lane and representative
Hill
that goes on consent okay
the next bill is 632
this is a bill that deals with the
Cooperative School District budget
committee
represent cordelli thank you I would
move itl
we have a motion made by represent
cordelli
itl second by reps and Miler that's on
632.
any discussion from the make of the
motion no give me a second welcome any
further discussion not seeing any
Madam clerk would you please call the
roll on 632
the motion is i t l
um
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative Lucas yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal
yes
representative Hill yes
representative Myler yeah representative
Howard yes representative Lane yes
representative luno yes representative
Woodcock yes representative Hall yes
representative Balboni yes
representative cascaden yes and
representative Damon yes and chairman
Ladd yes uh scores night score vote is
19-0
the score is 19-0 I love that everybody
good with consent here yes thank you
as long as the Red Sox are winning
okay
um
the next bill which we have is the
hearing that's scheduled at 1 30.
we can't start until 1 30 according to
rules of the house
so we're gonna have to lay low here for
20 minutes okay so I want to thank the
people that yes you can uh
representative Hill represent Lane
represent hours thank you very much for
standing in today appreciate it yeah
yeah
foreign
would that be a consent one night yeah
okay
yeah
introduce
going to go ahead with the next hearing
we have here it's on 516
HB 516 is relative to the freedom of
speech and Association of public
institutions of higher education
I trust everybody's having fun this
okay represent Papa Popovich Mueller
thank you very much
thank you and uh thank you to all the
members of the committee I normally try
to keep my remarks to committees to one
to three minutes I'm gonna ask for a
special dispensation for about five this
time because this is the most important
bill that I'll be talking about this
year and I would appreciate your
latitude
I need to start by saying that you know
I was born and raised in a communist
country I'm a naturalized citizen my
mother was a lifelong elementary teacher
she taught kids in first through fourth
grade I thought were living myself for a
decade I served on the Wyndham School
Board
so I'm telling you these things so you
understand both my commitment to free
speech based on where I'm coming from
and my commitment to education and my
understanding of those issues
but have been passed bills on this topic
this is a very different bill it's a
very clean language the concerns that
were expressed in the previous years
we've made every effort to address them
it is also a bipartisan bill I don't
consider such basic constitutional
rights to be a partisan matter I think
we all have an interest in freedom of
speech and freedom of Association and I
will continue to work on you know
getting bipartisan support for this bill
also for the record both of my bills
that I introduced are bipartisan and if
you look at all my other legislation I
co-sponsor the other co-sponsors go for
all Democrat to all Republican with
everything in between I support good
ideas regardless of who came up with
them
in terms of support HB 516 continues to
have support from fire AFP and a lot of
other organizations some of which are
present in the room but also for the
first time the support of ACLU they were
unable to commit to speaking here but
they you know confirmed to me in writing
they supported and they said they would
be signed in favor of the bill and I
think it's important to note the broad
support for this bill from organizations
all across the Spectrum
in terms of legislation I believe that
the best way to pass legislation that
will work and serve all of us is to work
on it in a Cooperative rather than an
adversarial manner so the prime sponsor
for the bill I spent a time and I
engaged with the ccsnh and UNH and you
know regardless of what the outcome of
this particular bill is I will continue
to stay in contact and be engaged with
them on those matters because they are
important
and the good news is that during those
meetings it was clear that we are all
committed to respecting the freedom of
speech and the freedom of Association on
campuses and that the difference is that
you know we may have tend to be over the
bills impact on policies and operations
and so on but we agree on the goals and
that's a really big deal right you have
a lot of legislation that is opposed
because we don't agree with the goals in
here we are in a better place
one of the questions that was asked was
exactly what does this bill do that is
not already covered by our policies and
our Federal Constitution and state
constitution and so on a couple of
answers but in a broad term in the
absence of this proposed chapter you
know 188j there is a lot of uncertainty
over what the boundaries are around
freedom of speech or Freedom Association
and these bills attempts to describe
them properly one clear area of
uncertainty is whether Free Speech zones
are acceptable as a policy
I this bill will make it clear that they
are not I do not believe that freedom of
speech means anything if you can only
exercise it in one corner of the campus
but you cannot do so in the rest of the
campus
you know the other area of legal
uncertainty addressed by this bill is
what kind of restrictions can we put on
student organizations in terms of
what is that nature of their beliefs or
can they require that members that join
them agree to the organization beliefs
complies with the organization code of
conducts and whatnot the language
proposed makes it clear that you know
we have to allow them to control their
membership we have to allow them to
treat them evenly and offer the same you
know support to all organizations
regardless of you know their beliefs
and I want to bring up something that I
already brought up in one of those
meetings there is a February 10
Story by the NH by nhpr on uh you know
somebody apparently creating secret
recordings of a UNH law school meeting
I'm bringing it up because obviously
it's public record and you know whatever
nhpr reported an HP are reported
but it's an example of the pressure that
colleges are under in the absence of a
legislation you know like the proposed
statute
case an hbr states that the discussion
on that meeting was around whether the
UNH should adopt an old Commerce policy
which I want to make very clear this
particular bill would not allow
think about it this way to use my town
of Windham our Democratic and Republican
Town committees restrict their
membership to Residents registered to
the respective parties
would you suggest that their freedom of
Association is expected if we would
force them to adopt all an all-commerce
policy and let anybody in would that be
meaningful would that associations mean
anything if they didn't have the choice
to choose who they want to associate
with same thing we have a very active
climate change group in Windham should
we allow them to accept anybody in their
meetings regardless of whether those
people take climate change seriously or
they think it's a hoax
you know should the American Legion we
have them on 111 be allowed to you know
that need people who are known draft
evaders well I'm reaching back about 50
years on that one but
the point is that I believe that the
freedom to associate is meaningless if
we require every Association to admit
anybody who applies regardless of what
the beliefs of the organization are or
whether they are you know really trying
to be productive in that Association or
not so
consider how much time and effort and
money has been spent on fighting these
battles which
presumably shouldn't be needed to be
spent or fought if we have a clear
statute where all the statute does is
highlights you know the neutrality
we don't want to be the Arbiters of this
we want to treat everybody equally and
look I want to protect the rights of the
minorities of the groups that don't have
you know the same protections as the you
know mainstream groups Maybe
those are the people who need the most
protection you know regardless of
whether they are on one side or the
other of the political spectrum and one
last point
most students do not have the resources
or the appetite for a legal challenge or
you know to even make a formal complaint
they are afraid of repercussions so we
cannot really measure whether you know
these uh
issues are happening how how extensive
those issues are just based on formal
complaints or on lawsuits being filed
there is a significant chilling effect
going way beyond that
and I want to make it very clear again
that I trust the commitment of our
public colleges and universities to
these goals I know that they are trying
to do their best I believe that this
bill passing it will help ensure that
they will be able to operate in the most
effective way while respecting the
freedoms of our students which you know
it is their stated goal to so I'm asking
for your support for this Bill thank you
thank you very much are there any
questions yes representative McDonald
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
bringing this forward and I truly do
mean that thank you there's a lot of
parts in this bill that I understand and
I see the value towards what I'm asking
is a part that I am confused about
personally it's on the last page and
line 20 it's the bottom two sections the
first is immunity and the next is
severability yep and in regards to those
sections do you know or are you aware of
a precedent for other
chapters within New Hampshire statutes
that wave federal constitutional rights
are you aware of Prior precedence for
this kind of language where it says to
waive immunity under the 11th Amendment
for example but any other
chapters in our RSA that say this that I
may not be aware of
I'm not aware of a particular essay that
has it but I think the language is
necessary because a lot of potential
lawsuits would not be able to proceed
because of the massive amount of
immunity that the state has and by
extension you know that extends to
organizations run by the state so if we
want to pass a statute that allows
people to seek recourse it has to
include their ability to you know
have their day in court
follow up please yes you may
so do you see the sections that I just
pointed out to as in any capacity being
in violation of uh federal statute or
federal constitutional rights or the
I believe that there is always the
possibility that claims under this bill
you know would not be you know be
allowed to proceed if this language
wasn't present so I I wouldn't have
you know kept that language if you know
I felt it was useless trust me just just
for the record if you compare this with
previous bills you'll notice how much
Slimmer it is we really try to
boil distill it to the essence of what's
needed so okay again thank you thank you
further questions from the committee yes
representative Luna thank you very much
um could you tell us a little bit about
how um 516 addresses the duty of care
um with respect to um uh all individuals
um I would appreciate if it clarify the
question because obviously the part of
the duty of care that I would you know
consider when talking about 5 16 is you
know the duty of protecting the rights
but I'm sure that there is something
else that I'm missing in that question
sure no happy to uh if I may Mr chair go
ahead so I'm really talking about things
like campus discourse and um and you
know respect for um uh for for all
persons on campus and uh obviously you
know violence doesn't doesn't belong you
know on campus in any situation so so uh
you know I think um uh campus employee
from my understanding is that we do have
representatives from the University
system here uh do have responsibility to
uh to uh through a duty of care to um um
to to you know make sure that um that
people are respected that discourse
that's that campus operations are not
disrupted and certainly that violence
doesn't break out
so I really appreciate your
clarification and I can very honestly
answer that this protects the every
legal possible right at the universities
have to deliver that duty of care while
at the same time making it clear where
the enforcement does need to stop you
know to be specific if you look at
section
um
188 J2 station Roman numeral three
and even in Roman numeral two if you
look at the second part of Roman numeral
two
the public institution of higher
education May maintain and enforce
reasonable time place and manner
restrictions applicable to traditional
public forums provided those
restrictions are narrowly tailored in
serviceable significant institutional
interest only
right so all that this is saying is
whatever rules you apply they should be
applied to everybody and they have to be
tailored so they are not overall
suppressive of speech it also you refer
to criminal activity there is
language further down right in section
Roman numeral three as long as the
person's conduct is not unlawful and
obviously you know you cannot be
disturbing the peace you cannot do any
kind of criminal activity absolutely
look I would never want to disrupt any
operations you know pass a law that
disrupts the operations of a campus or
prevents them from attending to the
safety
or just the main educational you know
mission that they have as as
universities this one specifically and
explicitly protects their ability to do
so we actually have positive language
not just the absence of language
restraining them we specifically say
that they are absolutely allowed to do
it to avoid any confusion and
there is a second part of your question
that I don't want to skirt around which
is that
at some point
when we talk about respecting others and
you know language that may be offensive
and I think that was part of what you
are asking about
that's where we get into clear
constitutional issues where universities
have consistently lost cases in which
they tried to go too far down those
paths so there are clear boundaries that
the Supreme Court you know has been
ruling on and I believe those are the
times when a university needs to focus
more on their educational nature and
educate
their students in what is acceptable and
what not while understanding that not
every disrespectful statement may be you
know avoided please also note that this
particular
legislation pertains to the outdoor
areas of the campuses we are not talking
about anything that happens in the
buildings we're just talking about the
public forums outside where people
traditionally you know hold signs and
they hold you know demonstrate publicly
we are not you know in any way going you
know covering anything that happens
inside the building in that freedom of
speech work sorry the statute is about
the outdoor areas on that now the
freedom of Association
that's a different topic and I don't
know if your question when was meant to
go there thank you
further questions from the committee yes
represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question firstly just to
quickly clarify up on the immunity
provision in here yes the 11th Amendment
to the Constitution only would prohibit
suits by non-citizens of the State of
New Hampshire so would you agree that
it's really kind of a minor issue
I would agree it's a minor issue but the
language is still there because you know
some students don't necessarily you know
consider themselves to be a resident of
the state and yet their rights should be
protected so it's it's
not a huge issue but it is an issue
that's large enough that coordines the
inclusion of the language thank you and
I have one other question if that's all
right
um when it comes to
prohibitive behaviors and things that
would be regulated by this bill I see
that violence and fighting I also see
that physically blocking is prohibited
but if the university were to allow for
instance a large number of students into
an auditorium that has been reserved for
a speaker and then they were further to
allow those students to shout down a
speaker
um is there any provisions in this bill
that would hold them accountable under
I'm trying to think because the intent
of the bill is to focus on the outdoor
areas I will say though that
you know what is in uh common terms
referred as a heckler's veto has been
consistently ruled to not be acceptable
and to be a violation of free speech and
I will also note that there is a large
number of times when
even law students and I'm not talking
about New Hampshire I'm thinking about a
case from another state but for the life
of me I cannot remember the exact name
of the University I can find the article
and send it to the committee later if
needed there was at least one case where
the very prestigious out-of-state Law
School
had a huge number of students who seem
to believe that Hitler's Vita was
protected somehow and they were not
infringing on Free Speech but again the
intent of this is to
cover it as you know much as possible
but
most of the
focuses again on outdoor areas thank you
further questions representative
woodcock
thank you chairman good afternoon thank
you for uh
getting some clarity for me I'm looking
on the you know it was line 28 or the
th2 it talks about any person who wishes
so do you know I was trying to compare
initially to the campus community that
identified people on the campus
administrators faculty staff those that
are associated and they had invited
guests but under 28 does this mean that
any person walking off the street who's
not affiliated with that institution of
High Learning again hold a protest of
some type on that campus
and I'm not sure yes thank you thank you
chairman another question represent
cordelli
thank you thank you for bringing this
forward uh just to follow up on that I
was also looking at sections two and
three on page two Romans two and three
in that um three seems to apply to a
non-campus community person
um but section two is for Camp the
campus community and the
um public institution is allowed to
enforce reasonable time place and manner
restrictions
um but would the institution be allowed
to uh enforce reasonable time place and
manner restrictions also on a
non-community member
um on enrollment three
I I would absolutely believe that all
those restrictions apply equally to
students or non-students I mean at the
end of the day when you look at the
language in Roman numeral two one eight
one eighty eight you know line 17
through 27 on page two
it clearly says it may maintain those
restrictions there is nothing in there
that says it's only applicable to
students who are applicable to anybody
else those those restrictions apply to
everybody the language in three is
merely clarifying that those rights are
not reserved to just registered students
they apply to you know other community
members but the restrictions would apply
you know to everybody
and that's part of what we were talking
about in some of our discussions with
the colleges that you know they require
permits in certain situations and
whatnot and again in my read this would
be as long as the those restrictions
meet the criteria they should be allowed
to continue enforcing them because they
are reasonable and you know
in alignment with the mission of the
institution
yes Paula
thank you
um looking over on page one
um and the previous question about uh
someone uh perhaps giving a talk in an
auditorium or other campus Building in
be under material materially and
substantially disrupts
um it says such protected conduct
includes but is not limited to protests
in outdoor areas so would this possibly
cover uh some disruptive behavior inside
a a campus Building for a speech of some
sort I'm very grateful for the question
because
and I don't think you'll hear people say
quite that quite often I realized as
soon as I finished answering the
representative belcher's question that I
completely completely
Miss under well I completely
misinterpreted my own legislation how
about that I apologize for that
while
the outdoor restrictions are necessary
to make sure that we don't have
three-speed zones or whatnot
the correct answer to your question and
to the correct answer to representative
Corvallis question is that yes anybody
trying to disrupt you know the
pre-speech of people under those
circumstances you know in a campus a
space reserve for that for such activity
would be a violation of the Free Speech
rights of whoever is that he's trying to
speak and again heckler's vetoes
I come from a country where freedom of
speech is not taken seriously and
we are in such a much better place but
it's still not okay to attempt to
silence others whether it's by not
allowing them to speak or by covering
their speech with noises that are so
loud that in effect you are doing the
same thing so yes I do appreciate the
opportunity to clarify and to correct my
previous misstatement and I'm grateful
for the opportunity thank you
representative a question for you I'm
looking at page two
line 26 and 27 where it reads nothing in
this section shall be interpreted as
limiting the right of student expression
Elsewhere on campus so now I'm looking
in the classroom itself
does this apply to a for example a
professor professor who is limiting
discussion or open engagement
open-minded discussion in the classroom
the intent of that section is to talk
about what is allowed in terms of
restrictions on the outdoor areas and
the last you know line the last well
nothing in this sections will be
interpreted that is just trying to
clarify that the rules that we Define in
paragraph in 188j2 are strictly
applicable to the outside and we are not
talking about those rules being
applicable in the indoor parts of the
campus I would say that that you know
does not really
add anything or remove anything from the
ability of the university to you know it
doesn't add anything to the ability it
does not that language does not allow
the university to
regulate the indoor in a similar manner
but in the past that has not really been
a concern it's generally the outdoors
that you know we've seen
the potential situations of free speech
zones that are concerning I'm not sure
if I correctly understood your question
could you clarify
why I can try to clarify there is a
recent article in the Wall Street
Journal which dealt with the University
of North Carolina North Carolina
where there's issues in history class
and other classes where now the trustees
have identified they're going to make a
new Department in which free speech is
allowed
that is a concern to me that we have to
go that far in higher ed to ensure that
free speech is going to be a a primary
goal of all of us in the classroom and I
was just hoping that
um that what you're putting in this bill
here when you say Elsewhere on on campus
of course buildings are Elsewhere on
campus
um is this applicable to a professor
shutting down discussion in a classroom
perhaps that discussion doesn't parallel
out that professor's perspective
it is not the intent of this paragraph
to be applicable in that area I'm also
very
comfortable right now with the way the
universities are handling those issues
in the classroom if there are issues in
the classroom that need to be addressed
you know I'm not aware of them right now
but no this is the
language in 188j2 paragraph 2 is about
what are the reasonable restrictions on
the outdoor areas and it speaks just to
that it does not speak to you know
anything that happens indoors thank you
represent Miler thank you Mr chair and
thank you for being here
this is not a new issue before this
committee
as I recall four years ago a similar
issue came before the committee and I
believe the group by the name of fire
was here and they basically uh indicated
that there was a problem uh in our
higher ed our state higher ed schools
about this
uh and the institution listened to what
that was said
uh the same issue came before us two
years ago
and fire was here to basically said the
institutions have complied with their
concerns
so my question to you uh representative
Popovich is what is your intent if you
could summarize for this committee your
intent of this bill please of course
allow me if I may to quickly acknowledge
the points that you made you are
absolutely correct the
overall respect for free speech and
freedom of Association has
been going in the right direction and I
do trust the commitment of our public
colleges and universities to you know
continue to do that this being said the
if there is ever a time when
institutions uh you know feel that it
would be appropriate to reverse that
Trend they are given very clear
guidelines on what is and what is not
acceptable and it is also intended to
clarify for everybody on campus
what the ground rules are in terms of
spray speech
one of the
reasons why this is still a heated
debate is that people can interpret the
constitution in different ways certain
things that may have been ruled
constitutional by the courts are things
that we don't think are a good idea and
again I will offer the Free Speech Zone
as a practice that has been documented
in many places outside of you know New
Hampshire that courts have ruled is
constitutional so this is intended to
clearly explain what the boundaries are
on free speech and freedom of
Association notwithstanding you know and
this has nothing to do
with you know doubting the commitment of
the universities to do the best they can
it's a recognition that we are all best
off when this is clearly defined in
statute and also by defining it into a
statute a lot of these fighting
will be decreased because there will be
clear things that students cannot
pressure the administration to fight for
I mean this whole discussion about
whether clubs should be you know open
you know membership or not
it's a gray area
and we want to clarify that and make
clear that that is not acceptable this
will prevent you know hopefully student
associations for asking for a stop that
clearly virus established statute while
right now because it is always set in
policy a lot of groups are trying to
pressure the universities to change
those policies and all that time and
effort frankly should be spent on better
topics please yes you may uh just a
follow-up are there any recent
incidences
that caused you to bring this before
frankly given the number of uh people
that are
lined up behind me to testify I'm Gonna
Leave the specific incidents to them
thank you very much thank you are there
further questions from the committee
Roxanne Luna
thank you very much Mr chair I'm just
wondering if um if because you you
talked a little bit about freedom of
Association as you know earlier and I
was wondering how you feel
um about colleges
um having uh you know a unique academic
Mission and core values that may be
distinct from uh from other institutions
um and whether or not those uh that
mission and core values those core
values should be protected and I'm
particularly asking this uh with
reference to the bottom of page two
spilling over to the top of Page Three
um uh where you talk about
um
um Roman one two and three and I'm just
looking at two you know while looking at
one which is core values Mission and
also number two and these are things
where the organ the um the leaders would
not be able to uh to protect uh
compliance with an organization
standards a con uh conduct or um core
values
there is a huge distinction between what
the private entity can do and what a
public entity can do
and I believe that
when we have a public College which is
an extension of the state government
we have a much higher burden on the
institution to protect the
constitutional rights of its students
where private institutions which by the
way are specifically left out of this
may have much more freedom in saying we
can enforce much tighter rules because
we are you know a part of the government
we have a much higher standard in you
know being able to impose those kinds of
restrictions so in a sense
we have a higher burden and that may
limit us from providing certain policies
that privacy institutions may decide are
applicable for them but because of who
we are
we have you know this level of
commitment to freedom of speech and
further questions from the committee Mr
chair appreciates who when when the
university system testifies that they
can address some of those comments too
thank you when they come up right
terrific thank you for the questions of
the representative thank you very much
thank you you're welcome uh
foreign
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee and I I promise I won't I
won't try to bug out early this time I
don't
um uh I I
um my name is Bob Nguyen I'm a
representative from Windham and I appear
here in support of uh this legislation
um I think I I guess I would like to say
a couple things first of all I think
representative papamichi Mueller uh you
know he he I think he covered the the
the area on the important things very
well and I don't have a tremendous
amount to add but what I what I would
add is I think that
um
unlike and I had some involvement last
last uh last time in another bill that
was sort of some like somewhere like
this and to be honest with you I don't
even remember what what uh what the uh
what the result of that I mean it didn't
obviously didn't pass but
um there were I think that there were
some concerns about the
constitutionality of at least some parts
of that earlier bill
from my review of this I really don't
think that there's a that there's a
constitutional issue here with anything
that's been proposed here I don't think
anything in this would be
unconstitutional
um and I think it does add
um the uh it it does
supplement the Constitution by providing
at least in some areas additional
protection as representative
Mueller's indicated there are you know
there are apparently some cases around
the country that say that you can have
you know you can have a free speech Zone
however limited somewhere on campus and
that's that's so that's sufficient to uh
to satisfy the requirement of of you
know providing alternative places for
speech it's uh you know you can't help
thinking that that that's sort of like
saying you know the the the dog pound is
over here and and if you are one of the
one of those disreputable people that
wants to engage in free speech then you
can go to the you can go to the dog
pound this this says no you can't do
um that kind of thing and so I think I
think it I think it is it's it serves an
important purpose
um and I think it I um I think it is uh
is a worthwhile bill and I just there
was one point that I wanted to uh
reference I think uh representative
Belcher you had raised the question
about the 11th Amendment immunity and
you know it's true if you read the 11th
Amendment it says it appears to say only
that it bars suit in federal courts by
citizens of one State against uh against
another state but almost from the
beginning after the 11th Amendment was
was uh adopted the U.S Supreme Court has
interpreted it to mean it's not just
citizens of another state it's you can't
sue your own state in federal court
unless there's been some waiver of
immunity so I think uh I I think
you know do you absolutely have to have
the 11th Amendment waiver in here no I
suppose if you even without the 11th
Amendment waiver
the second sentence of section j6 which
says a public institution of higher
education that violates this chapter
shall not be immune from suit or
liability for the violation that by
having that sentence alone if you took
the first sentence out that would allow
suit to be brought in State Court
um against you know the University of
New Hampshire as an example
um but I do think that having the first
sentence in there serves a useful
purpose because it basically says if
someone wants to bring a suit in federal
court
that would otherwise be be barred by the
11th Amendment the the state of New
Hampshire has waived the 11th Amendment
for this for these for purposes of these
suits and I think that serves a useful
function
um so I I you know that's why I I
support
thank you I'm happy to take questions I
have one question for you maybe help me
understand this
um
at one point it gives us a definition in
then on the last page
on line seven it says any person or
Student Association agreed by a
violation may do this this and this
is Student Association and student
organization the same thing
you know that's that's really a good
catch I would say yes that that it's
meant but you know there's a principle
in the law that says if if the
legislature meant the same thing they
would use the same word and if they
didn't they must have meant something
else so that might be you know it might
be it might be worthwhile there for this
Committee in its wisdom to change to
change that so that the word is the same
so that you use the same word in both
places so that you prevent that argument
from being made some you know if you
don't make that's a really good catch if
you don't make that kind of change
somewhere down the road some lawyer will
say oh no no no wait a minute they said
organization on page two and Association
on page three and there must be some
some difference
um so I you know I think that would make
sense to uh to uh thank you to make
those things consistent it's good to
hear from a judge
okay further questions represent
McDonald thank you Mr chair and thank
you very much for clarifying my
questions regarding the 11th Amendment
and the waiver of immunity however I am
still hung up on the part that comes
after that could you tell me if I'm
interpreting this correctly where it
if any provision is held Beyond
constitutional
the application of the provision to any
other person or circumstance shall not
be affected is that to mean that if
something is found Beyond constitutional
to one person but it's constitutional to
the next person is
saying yeah you know what this is this
is language that has actually become
somewhat standard in in legislation not
just in New Hampshire but around the
country and and the idea is
there's a there's a Doctrine in the law
that that
sometimes a court if a court says
the you know in some lawsuit this
statute is unconstitutional
depending on the circumstances they
might they might say that it's
sort of facial for lack of a better term
facially Constitution unconstitutional
it can never be applied as to anyone
and as opposed to
the court saying
this statute is unconstitutional as
applied to this plaintiff in this case
but it's not you know we don't we we
don't address whether it's
constitutional anywhere else and what
this is designed to what this is
designed to say is to send a signal to
the court
the legislature intends you Court to
apply this only to individual cases so
if you think that in some particular
case the statute's unconstitutional okay
then then you rule that it's
unconstitutional as to that case but our
intent the legislature is to have it is
to not have you say it's always
unconstitutional it's basically say you
know if there's another case that comes
up you decide afresh whether it's
constitutional in that context or not
that that's kind of what it's designed
to to do because sometimes the court
will the courts have said well you know
without this for example if this this
language we're not in there well
we think that you know the legislature
probably wouldn't have wanted if if the
legislature had known that this statute
was unconstitutional as to this case it
wouldn't have wanted the statute to
exist at all so we're going to say it's
unconstitutional as to every case Okay
this language is designed to say don't
do that court all right I appreciate the
clarification thank you thank you for
the questions yes reps in a Ford
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you for
taking my questions
um in a recent case in excuse me thank
you
in a recent case in Pennsylvania a
faculty member is said now I was not
there so I'm going on who's in personal
accounts from former colleagues
was alleged to have asserted in a
classroom that there are only that are
more than two genders of human beings
a student objected to the statement
based on religious grounds and other
claims I don't know what they were
and they're developed a dispute between
the faculty member and the student in
class
at some point the student was rejected
from the class in some process protested
unfortunately it was a class required
for graduation which was the next
semester and
it became an entire dispute over
Truth for one person and Truth for
another person
the student was ejected suspended from
the school that position was then
reversed later and the student was
allowed to somehow graduate how would
that kind of a case be addressed
by this kind of a bill I'm not I don't
think that this bill particularly I mean
you know the the the issue and I think
representative lad one of your questions
to the representative kind of uh
raised this issue too I think one of the
things this this statute doesn't really
deal with the issue and it's a
complicated issue of
the faculty member
who is a state employee and what the
faculty member can or cannot say
um and you know what what what may
result from what the faculty member says
because on the one hand you do have a
Doctrine you know of sort of academic
freedom that the professor should be
allowed to you know to explore and
shouldn't be restricted
um uh in you know or curtailed in like
their academic Pursuits that you have
that and that's and and the money and
that's an important Doctrine on the
other hand
you have the fact that the that the
professor is a state is an employee of
the state is being paid by the state and
just to give you an obvious example
suppose a professor has hired you know
to to teach in the math department
I don't I think the state can properly
say if the professor decides you know
today I really want to talk about
history we're gonna we're gonna I'm
gonna give you you know we're gonna have
a lecture on history that the state can
say wait a minute you know we did that's
not what we're paying you for you're you
want to talk about history that do it on
your own time get the students out you
know after class or whatever talk about
it but but we're paying you to be a math
teacher you can't be a history teacher
now you know that's at one extreme On
The Other Extreme if the teacher is
talking about history and is expressing
um uh you know an offhand personal view
on something is that
um you know is that somehow a violation
of the of the professor's uh of the
professor's job description and that
it's it becomes it can become very you
know it can become very complicated
depending on the circumstances
further questions from the committee yes
represent Belcher thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question
um just to return to something I'd asked
earlier do would you agree that this
um the language in this creates a rate
of action if a college were to allow a
um a speaker to be shouted down and if
so can you can you tell me where the
language might be because I'm having a
hard time finding specific language that
would address a situation like that I
think it I think it would I mean it
would it would I guess it would sort of
depend on the again on the particular
circumstances but for example let's
suppose you had a situation where
you know the colleges
routine practice was when
whenever you know they that they did not
they did not try to restrict you know
controversial speechers speakers from
coming on campus and they you know when
they when they knew that something was
likely to be controversial they'd make
sure they had enough security people
around but
you know for this particular speaker
uh uh of of a particular political
political persuasion uh they didn't have
any security that day you know they all
all the campus police decided to take
vacation that day or whatever
um sure I think that and then if you
know if they're developed as a result of
that somebody couldn't speak or there
turned out to be uh you know a riot in
effect I think I think yes there might
very well be a basis for liability thank
you further questions representative
Luna and then representative Lane thank
you very much Mr chair are you aware
that um that that a lot that the
language in here appears to be Alec
model legislation I was not aware of
um thank you representative Lynn for
taking my question
um and I probably should have asked this
of the other speaker but
um why is this only applicable to public
schools and not private schools as well
because the state the state action issue
in other words you if the if something
if something is not a a state
institution I think there's a there's a
a much bigger question about what's the
legislators legislature's authority to
regulate it I'm not saying I'm not
saying that there that there isn't any
but I'm just saying it becomes
it becomes a more complicated issue and
I just I think representative Mueller
may have touched on this a little bit or
but but I know in discussions I've had
with him I mean one of the things that
you know that that
um we focus on is Let's uh we think this
is important for protecting the first
amendment is really important let's you
know but let's not try to go into an
area that that maybe is beyond what
where or at least would raise questions
as to the legislature the authority to
do that and and I would you know I just
give you an example in my in my
committee we had the we had a proposal
uh legislation was proposed for us to on
a state level to regulate uh the con you
know what what Google and uh Twitter and
all that can do uh and there was a and
there was a real question about the
First Amendment implications of do we
have the right to do that so I think
that's the issue here with regard to
private institutions
representative balbooni
thank you chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um time on page two
lines 34 and 35. it talks about
ways that public institutions
are not uh let me just read it here so
nothing in the section shall be
interpreted of preventing public
institutions of higher education from
prohibiting limiting or restricting
expression that the First Amendment does
not protect such as and these are the
words true threats expression directed
to provoke eminent
of all those actions and likely to
produce it
those are those legal terms those how do
you determine what is a true threat or
the expression um up above he that the
harassment is defined but those two are
not
you know it they yeah I think the short
answer is yes they are I mean those are
terms that are that have been used
repeatedly in court cases including
Supreme Court cases
um this those those kinds of things
um that you know that the First
Amendment doesn't there are certain
things the first amendment doesn't
protect and you know the the classic
example is you can't yell fire in a
crowded theater if there's really no
fire you just can't you you know just
been starting to Stampede and there are
other things obscenity is another
another uh example
um but but and I think so I think this
tries to capture that and I think the it
it it's it's important to Define
harassment because I think
one of the things that has been a real
issue I think lately
is
you know the whole idea of sort of hate
speech quote unquote hate speech
um being in some circles that the the
thought is that hate speech is not
protected by the First Amendment which I
think is really problematic because
often what it really means is hate
speech is when you say something that I
disagree with really strongly that's
hate speech and that's a real you know
that's a real problem uh I I think a
real problem to allow government to do
that kind of thing I you know I think
we've one of the things that I would
remind you of is remember back not that
long ago 1977 when the American Nazi
party wanted to wanted to have a
demonstration in Skokie Illinois
and which is a you know heavily Jewish
suburb of Chicago and the Supreme Court
said yep they can and the ACLU the ACLU
supported them I I think I happen to
think that the Supreme Court made the
right decision there even though you
know the I the idea of a Nazi party
turns my stomach and I'm sure it does
all of yours
um
but I I think we have to be careful that
we don't slip away from that however
offensive we might think some particular
view is that that doesn't make it you
know violence
um or the or the or the threat of
violence there has to actually be some
threat of violence to for something to
become not not covered by the First
Amendment and so I think the harassment
definition which says it's not just
somebody made some really offensive
comment there's got to be it's got to be
something that that really
um meets the definition uh that the
student you know it's uh subject it's uh
so severe pervasive and subjectively and
objectively offensive that the student
is denied equal is denying equal access
to uh to educational opportunities if
it's something less than that
um then it doesn't then it doesn't
qualify and you can't stop it represent
balbon if you have yeah just a follow-up
um just back to what you're coming about
the harassment who determines that I
mean who is who is the final who makes
the final decision on what constitutes
harassment well I guess I mean if it was
a lawsuit I think it would end up being
the court that would decide the court
that would decide that and if there were
factual issues about what happened maybe
a jury maybe a jury would decide but but
uh you know if the facts were not in
dispute then a court I think would
ultimately have to decide
thank you further questions
thank you very much thank you thanks
and then thank you chair and Ladd by
sharing cordelli and members of the
committee my name is Greg Gonzalez and
I'm a legislative Council for the
foundation for individual rights and
expression also known as fire fire is a
non-partisan non-profit organization
dedicated to protecting free speech and
due process rights of students and
faculty at our nation's institutions of
higher education throughout its over 20
year history buyers depends students and
faculty on all parts of the political
Spectrum we have also advocated for
campus free speech legislation in state
houses across the country
I'm here I'm here in support of HB 516
this bill guarantees crucial First
Amendment protections at New Hampshire's
institutions of higher education
first the bill would designate outdoor
areas of Campus as public forums this
would effectively ban so-called Free
Speech zones these are often small
remote areas that impermissibly
quarantine expressive activity to
isolate corners of Campus
over 20 states have already enacted laws
to ban so-called Free Speech zones
further the bill helpfully and carefully
defines a line between constitutionally
protected protests and unprotected
heckler's vetoes
New Hampshire's public institutions of
higher education have maintained
policies in the past that have severely
eliminated student speech rights for
instance the University of New Hampshire
had a policy in the past that requires
two organizations to get their fire
their flyers and pamphlets they sought
to distribute pre-approved by the campus
police chief that blatantly
unconstitutional policy was on the books
for some time thankfully after working
with fire to revise such policies the
University of New Hampshire now receives
fire fires highest green light speech
code rating me it has no speech codes
that seriously imperil Free Speech
rights I'm also happy to note that UNH
ranked 16th of 203 colleges and fires
2022 called free free speech rankings
now is the time to statutorily lock in
the speech protective policies
the bill also attempts to protect
students from over broad harassment
codes which are the most common forms of
speech restriction on college campuses
Bill does this by adopting the speech
protective definition of student on
student harassment set forth by the
United States Supreme Court in Davis
versus Monroe County Board of Education
fire urges the passage of this bill and
as always fire is open to working with
universities on these policies to ensure
they protect expressive rights and pass
constitutional muster
thank you for your time and
consideration and I'm happy to answer
any of your questions thank you very
I have a written copy of my testimony as
good afternoon my name is Tim Chevalier
I'm a New Hampshire Citizen and a local
attorney and I'm a member of the
Christian legal Society I speak today on
his behalf in sport of house bill 516.
and I respectfully request that the
letter chairman lad from the Christian
legal Society its attachments be
included in the record
the Christian legal Society is an
association of Christian attorneys law
students and law professors with student
Chaps at approximately 121 law schools
Nationwide
CLS student chapters typically are small
groups of students who meet for weekly
prayer Bible study and worship at a time
and place convenient for the students
all students are welcome to participate
in meetings as chapter members
as Christian groups have done for nearly
two millennia
CLS requires this chapter of leaders to
agree with a statement of faith the
traditional Christian beliefs that
Define cls's message and Mission
House Bill 516 is a common sense measure
that would protect students who wish to
meet on college campuses in New
Hampshire for religious political or
ideological speech I will focus my
remarks on religious students need for
protection
that house bill 516 would provide
specifically section
118-j3 is intended to protect religious
students who want to meet on a public
college campus by prohibiting College
administrators from denying the meeting
space because a religious Student
Association requires leaders or members
to adhere to association's sincerely
held religious beliefs
comply with the association's sincere
religious standards of conduct
or be committed to furthering the
association's religious mission
too often the CLS has seen College
administrators threatened to exclude
religious groups
because the groups require their leaders
to share the group's core religious
beliefs
the need for this bill was demonstrated
just this year when the student fire
Association at the University of New
Hampshire school of law threatened to
deny recognition to the Christian legal
Society law Student Chapter there
the University of New Hampshire website
lists 327 student organizations
the law school website lists 28 student
organizations from across the Spectrum
the last five public hearing the SBA
threatened to deny the cls's request for
recognition
because they claim that the requirements
there's leaders agree with religious
beliefs violated the school's diversity
equity and inclusion policies
the CLS student leaders were subjected
to Inquisition by the SBA into their
religious beliefs
the SBA made clear their hostility to
these beliefs
to defend the students CLS sent a letter
to University administrators they
expanded failure to recognize a chapter
was unconstitutional Viewpoint
discrimination
the administration agreed
and may direct the SBA to recognize CLS
which it did
but CLS remains concerned that the
Student Chapter May face similar tax
next fall
when it reapplies for recognition
if this bill with a law the Student
Chapter would not have to worry well
I'll be clearer
the regulation process shorter and less
dramatic of course common sense and
basic religious freedom
for a religious Association to expect
its leaders to agree with the
association's religious beliefs
it should be common ground that
government officials including College
administrators should not interfere with
their religious beliefs practices
standards of conduct remission of
religious associations
that's basic separation of church and
state
furthermore please note that the bill
allows public colleges to adopt whatever
policy they wish
it only requires that their policies be
applied in a way
that ensures that religious student
groups are not excluded from campus
because their speech including a
requirement their leaders should agree
with their beliefs
this bill also conserves scarce taxpayer
dollars by preventing costly litigation
as mentioned earlier the uncertainty in
the law there's an example here from the
University of Iowa what does it pay a
half million dollars attorney's fees
after a dispute in this area
in the fellow Court of PLS found that
University officials could be personally
liable to students for damages as well
so this bill protects College
administrators as well as college
students
finally by passing this bill
New Hampshire joined the experiment list
of 17 states that enacted similar
protections for religious or
belief-based student groups
thank you for consideration and please
pass House Bill 516. thank you very much
are there any questions from the
committee
thank you very much I'd like to invite
the university system New Hampshire
good afternoon and thank you for this
opportunity to testify on HB 516 I offer
this testimony on behalf of the
University system of New Hampshire is
Board of Trustees and its component
institutions the University of New
Hampshire Keene State College and
Plymouth State University
usnh is committed to ensuring all
students employees and members of the
public fully enjoy the rights to free
speech assembly and Association
guaranteed by the First Amendment to the
United States Constitution In Articles 2
4 5 and 22 of New Hampshire state
constitution
each unsnh institution has policies
fully compliant with each of those
provisions and the substantial body of
case law decided under them these
policies recognize the centrality of the
First Amendment to campus life see for
instance the UNH policy and outside
speakers which states that the basis
underlying the policy is quote the Bill
of Rights in the United States
Constitution the rights of freedom to
speech and Peaceable assembly are to be
fully protected thank you
I was just mentioned by an earlier uh
commenter each of our institutions has
earned a green light rating from the
foundation for individual rights and
education for free speech policies that
appropriately balance the educational
missions of our institutions with
opportunities for the free and robust
exchange of ideas of the 647 colleges
and universities given a green yellow
red or blue light reading by fire this
year only 60 approximately one in ten
were awarded a green light three of
those institutions were UNH Durham
Plymouth State and King state
this demonstrates that HB 516 is not
necessary because existing campus
policies and practices already comply
with the extensive body of fate of
federal and state constitutional law on
these issues enacting a new state law is
likely to cause confusion and ambiguity
and I'll depart from my prepared remarks
here just to note I think we've already
seen here today simple that confusion
ambiguity about to the extent this bill
would not apply to indoor events or
classroom instruction or maybe most
importantly how wood or would not change
our ability to handle disruption caused
by folks from outside our community and
however much confusion or ambiguity
you're looking for angles there aren't
here I promise you that the plaintiff's
bar is going to be even better at
finding them
um uh this new law would would replace
that existing well-developed body of law
which is rooted directly in the First
Amendment with new language whose
requirements and limits cannot be no
uncertainty the ambiguity invariably
leads to lawsuits and the waste of The
Limited public resources appropriated
for the provision of higher education in
New Hampshire
permitting processes for outdoor
assembly at East our institutions
establish reasonable time place and Mana
restrictions and are administered in a
Viewpoint neutral way the processes work
well and are responsive to the neat
challenges of ensuring safety on each
campus the historical lack of legal
challenges to these outdoor event
policies shows that the existing
procedures work and are flexible enough
to address the Myriad of events that
occur on campuses as an example a UNH
current policies allow for spontaneous
student Gatherings of less than 25
people without a permit provided the
assembly event or assembly does not
disrupt normal operations students are
also allowed to distribute literature
and or solicit contributions on an
individual basis at any time without a
permit the permitting process for larger
events ensures that Public Safety and
Facilities Management considerations can
be addressed in advance and individuals
or organizations can be held accountable
for things like property damage and
cleanup of litter the applications are
evaluated based on specified criteria
that are Viewpoint neutral and provide
an appeal processing even of a denial
HP 516 would impose additional financial
and administrative burdens on U.S and
age institutions particularly by
increasing the need for campus safety
officers at a time when every effort is
being made to reduce overhead and costs
in order to keep tuition down
in addition HP 516 if passed will
provide plaintiffs in their lawyers
incentives in the form of both potential
Financial penalties and the province of
attorney's fees for suing us U.S NH
institutions this would increase the
costs incurred by U.S Nation defending
litigation even though our policies are
in full compliance with the First
Amendment for these reasons U.S Nation
respectfully urges the committee to vote
HP 516 in Expedia to legislate thank you
for the opportunity to offer this
testimony and I'm happy to answer any
questions if folks happen thank you very
much are the questions of the University
system representative Myler thank you Mr
chair and thank you for being here I
have two questions
in the previous those testimony there
was an indication that there was a
problem at the UNH law
uh with the Christian Community has that
question one has that been resolved yes
as I believe the speaker mentioned the
administration noted the issue and the
COS has been recognized secondly uh
representative Lynn talked about a dog
pound
uh for free speech zones do you have a
dog pound at uh UNH and if so where is
it uh not to my knowledge representative
so you you don't have a designated place
no so we don't have a dog pound no so
UNH um the institutions differ slightly
on this
um the Campus Community is allowed uh as
I mentioned here for UNH small
Gatherings don't require any permit can
take place essentially any place on
campus already some of the campuses go
above and beyond for people outside the
community and establish areas where
people from outside the community can
cook and uh come and speak on manageable
public importance they are centrally
located at Keene State it's on Oya Hill
which is the highest point on campus
there are multiple such places at
Plymouth State
um and again so that that those are
going above they all roll up what we're
required to do in terms of allowing
folks from outside the community to come
and and speak without prior permitting
thank you just one follow-up please yes
uh has the university system had any
complaints or legal issues brought
before them as it relates to free speech
in the last two years
not to my knowledge thank you very much
further questions representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um I see here and you've pointed to the
fact that your institutions have
improved to earning a green light rating
from fire and certainly as commendable
but in the time that that has improved
there has not been to my belief a
presidential election cycle
impressed in past Cycles
um such as the last one I had looked
forward to hearing from a conservative
commentator by the name of Dave Reuben
at one of these um events
and instead of hearing from him uh
students were allowed to shout him down
despite security presence the security
was ordered not to do anything about
this and the event wound up not being
able to go forward so I'd ask without
such something such as this on the books
what assurances can we have that in the
next presidential election cycle
so I I think the first my first response
would be as noted earlier it's not
entirely clear what effect this bill
would have on an indoor event like such
as the one I I think you're describing I
don't I don't know what those indoors or
Outdoors but I'm getting the sense that
it was indoors so the answer very
specifically to this bill is I don't
know and you'll hear this a lot in my
testimony is I'm not sure in a lot of
instances what the effect of the passage
of this bill would be around operations
and that's the source of a lot of our
concerns
thank you further questions represent
luno
thank you very much Mr Sharon and thank
you very much Mr pimental for joining us
this afternoon could you talk a little
bit about
um UNH unh's policies or maybe
University Systems policies as it um as
it relates to um to uh events that might
be designed to intimidate or disrespect
so uh each of our campuses has cancer
discrimination policies the extent to
which a given event does or does not
violate those policies is very fact
specific and so it's difficult to speak
in the abstract
um I think one of the the the real
foremost challenge is facing not just us
and H but all higher ed institutions
right now certainly public ones
um is the push and pull between
respecting the need for free speech and
the value of free speech and trying to
foster a campus client climate where
everyone feels comfortable volunteering
their opinion and I don't know that any
institution has gotten it exactly right
yet
we are pleased with the way that we are
striking that balance right now and any
additional change that might come
legislatively that could affect that
balance is we find it difficult to
predict the effect that would have on
our campuses
yes thank you Mr chair and um uh is
there a potential conflict I guess
between
um uh what you have as those current
policies uh those current um uh
anti-discrimination non-discrimination
policies and um and maybe what the uh
what some of the what what a consequence
of some of the provisions in 5 16 I
think we would have to go back
institution by institution and review
each policy against it in the event that
this or something like it passed um
again I I apologize for Circle back to
this part of the answer is I just don't
know because as was noted uh earlier in
response to representative's question
ultimately a lot of these questions
would have to be answered by a court as
to what sort of conduct Rose to the
level of harassment and uh the
university system would be forced to pay
for the privilege of finding out in
litigation okay thank you uh I do have a
question
um
this this bill carries a fiscal note or
at least uh there's uh several Pages uh
dealing with that and according to the
community college system New Hampshire
and the university system of New
Hampshire you're unable to determine
costs that might be associated with this
since this has been filed has to been
any uh more work done on this to try to
determine what the cost might be
there has been more work done but we
aren't really any closer to having
something we could present to the
committee uh in sort of good faith
because a lot of it will depend on the
extent to which particularly outside
folks come on to our campuses and have
large uh demonstrations that will
require additional campus safety
response may require additional cleanup
costs and that sort of thing so it's at
the end of the day we are fully in
control of what the cost would be
because we are it would be responding to
outside forces on that
thank you further questions
yes represent woodcock
good afternoon and thank everything my
question uh you referred to
representative miles question who's
talking about the last two years of the
history at the campus
um and the green lights East uh my
question is two parts uh this particular
piece of legislation or proposed
legislation deals with cannabis
activities outside
um my question to you then is one and
I'm not sure the answer I wouldn't ask
it I'll try to set you up here the green
light involved inside and outside
evaluations of facilities which is
outside it's question one and okay the
chairman shuts me off uh has there been
any other any issues inside as relative
to public free speech so so my
understanding of the Green Light reading
and if I misrepresent then I can maybe
the fire deal more contact me on the
back is that it is uh an overall rating
of free speed of policies touching free
space issues across different areas okay
so one would be is your anti-harassment
policy sufficiently specifically limited
one would be what is your outside policy
the outside speakers what is your policy
on outside events and you average all
those together and they generate a
rating thank you and the second part
about I mean
quickly thank you sir the second part
about has there been any incidents uh
and the University Systems of the three
there uh and inside the last two years
of problems I'm not aware of anything
that's reason the level of a lawsuit
certainly I can't I there's active
discussion about these issues all the
time on campus so I hesitate to say
there's never been a dispute but there's
not been a filing that I'm aware of okay
thank you thank you thanks chairman
you're welcome represent Belcher thank
you Mr chairman I just wanted to follow
up in your question as far as uh
expenses are concerned with the
insurance free speech access and whatnot
and to that effect I wanted to ask do
you know what the current state is of
the endowment of the University of New
Hampshire
yeah embarrassingly had to say that I
don't that that's that's uh Beyond where
we're going with this bill we can get
that figure
um
I'm a trustee of the University system I
can get that figure for you but I don't
see how it relates necessarily to this
bill well just in terms of cost oh
I I will say that the largest source of
funding for the University system is the
tuition dollars of our students yeah
further questions
thank you very much
I'd like to invite Brian
muh you
thank you for having me my name is uh
Brian mu I grew up in New Hampshire in
Littleton New Hampshire uh went to the
University of New Hampshire and married
a girl from New Hampshire and everyone
knew that we would wind up back in New
Hampshire before I wound up back in
Pennsylvania
but I'm back now uh and I'm a campus
staff minister with intervarsity
Christian fellowship at the University
of New Hampshire uh the section of this
bill that particularly applies
um to the students that we work with is
188 j3 and as you heard the story of the
Christian legal Society
um that is also uh a concern for us so
one of the things that student religious
groups do is they offer a place on
campus for people who have that same
religious tradition and so it's
important that the leaders the student
leaders of those organizations
share those uh same values as well and
so so yeah so so every year we we do go
through a re-recognition process and so
it is
um yeah it's good for our organizations
it's good for our students to be able to
say yes we know that we can actually
have students who are practicing our
faith and that's true across any faith
so we happen to be a Christian
organization but the the same token you
know to have
um our Muslim student organizations say
yes we want you to
um to have a you know a Muslim faith
Jewish organizations the same kind of
thing if you have an atheist a humanist
uh student organization you want them to
also share those values as well
uh and so
um so that becomes our interests and
that uh enables us to then serve the
campus well we would love it if everyone
would be a member
um and so we have no membership
restrictions
um as uh in our constitution but we do
uh want to see leaders be able to say
yes I I subscribe to this
um so thank you thank you very much are
there questions from the committee
representative Myler thank you Mr chair
so the you heard the testimony before
from the University regarding uh the
ability to have 25 uh groups of 25
Etc have you had any problems in your
faith-based organization in uh being
able to participate on campus
we have not had any uh problems at the
University assistant in New Hampshire
now thank you very much rep San Luna
thank you Mr chair do any of the um
student religious associations at the
University of New Hampshire receive
funding from uh from the University
in order to operate yes so um so as a
student organization uh there is um
equal access to a student organization
funding
um and that is determined uh by the
Student Activities Committee
yeah so thank you and are any of them uh
are are some of them not funded and if
so what would be the reason for that
so uh as part of being a recognized
student organization recognize student
organizations to have access to Student
Activity fee funding so if you had an
unrecognized student group they are not
recognized and recognition is really
um the idea that
uh by having a um
by having students uh by asking student
leaders subscribe to uh to the faith
represented by the student organization
the mission of that student organization
um
the idea that you would then be
unrecognized by having that requirement
is
um that would be the challenge and that
would limit access to uh to religious
community on campus and with the yeah I
think related to to this
um with the with the bill on um very
bottom of page two on top of Page Three
I know you don't have it in front of you
right now where it says um
it basically says to the to the effect
um no public and higher education shall
deny religious political
radiological student organization any
benefit or privilege available to any
other student organizations would that
change the um the the would that be a
change from the policy you just talked
about so that would uh codify the
current policies that are in place
that you'd have to be a recognized yes
yeah thank you further questions now see
thank you very much I'd like to invite
thank you Mr chair and thank you
honorable members of the committee uh
for the record my name is Owen Reed I
represent Rockingham 10 new market and
new fields and um
I'm going to to speak very broadly
because I'm not a lawyer nor am I an
education expert although um I have
adjunct taught for many semesters
American government and Community
College so that's kind of the level I'll
I'll come to this end and um I guess I
want to answer the question why a
self-described far leftist agnostic
atheist secular person such as myself
might show up in support for something
that I think probably unjustly may have
gotten a reputation for being
right meaning and that's because Free
Speech isn't a right-leaning concept and
historically in fact if you want to
conjure images of students protesting
the Vietnam War or fighting for women's
rights or fighting for civil rights
um it has been I think alternating left
or right and that's because it's it's an
issue of fairness it's an issue of
making sure that one particular side
doesn't have the power to suppress the
other and I would also argue just on a
personal level as someone who teaches
American government that when our
Founders put this in our the first set
of amendments and what was the Bill of
Rights that it was radically leftist
according to traditional lock-in
definitions of what that is
so um
the reason that this is super important
is because if you have in place an
ability to censor people then now it's
up to the limbs of whoever happens to
get into power
so it kind of I was going to wait and to
address issues that were brought up but
I wanted to bring up why why if there's
no problems why do we do this
I'm glad there's no problem super glad
that there's no problems right now but
if you wait until there are problems
then it's too late
because if the systems exist to allow
suppression then whoever gets empowers
are able to use those systems this is
how I teach my my students I say that
the constitution is like the rules in a
in a box of Monopoly right you follow
the rules and as long as we're following
the rules people seem okay no matter who
wins or loses because everybody played
according to the rules but if somebody
just overturns the game and just breaks
all the rules then you're going to get
anger right because I think that we
we're experiencing so much divisiveness
in our in our country and I think a lot
of times people talk about well it's the
right versus the left it's you know
these ideas it's because they disagree I
don't think it's because they that the
sides disagree that we have so much
bitterness the market of place of ideas
is important which is why we need
protection free speech I think it's the
lack of good faith engagement the idea
that we don't trust the other side to
play by the rules to play by that
Monopoly rule set that that came with
our country right the Constitution we
don't trust the other side we think
they're going to cheat for lack of a
better word
and that's what causes the bitterness
and so I think it's really important
that I being on the other side of so
many of the sponsors of this bill come
forward in good faith to say yeah
actually it's a good idea to protect
Free Speech even if in this particular
situation it might be impacting you more
but that means later maybe you'll listen
I am a very strong believer on voting on
issues voting on bills as a legislator
based on the merits of the bill and not
based on personality or party
um but I'm not so naive to think that we
are not flawed human beings that
sometimes give into unconscious
biases against people we see to be on
the other side so I wanted to very
expressly show my face here today
because this is not a partisan issue
it's a partisan issue in a particular
moment but then it becomes the other
so let's see I think I'm about done
um just a couple issues that were
brought up so the outdoor versus indoor
I want to point out again that the uh
second page line 13 this is Roman number
one that covers all areas including
indoor in fact it says all forms
including guest speakers and what have
you so that that includes indoor section
two is what specifically relates to
Outdoors so indoor is covered there
um the shouting down
of a speaker that that is covered the
the definition on the first page of uh
three material Inception substitute
substantially disrupts means when a
person with the intent to or knowledge
of doing so significantly hinders
another person or groups expressive
activity which occurs in the campus
space reserve for such activity under
the exclusive user control of that
particular person or group prevents the
communication of the message prevents a
transaction the business or lawful
meeting Gathering work procession by Etc
that is specifically for if the
University
has said this person's allowed to speak
you don't get to disrupt the
University's proceedings and it that's
the definition but that definition is
referenced in uh section and our Roman
numeral two on the second page where
it's talking about reasonable time
placing manner restrictions applicable
to traditional public forums
um in service of a significant
institutional interest so again if an
institution has brought a speaker on the
students can't disrupt that and then
down in Roman rule 3 materially in
substantially substantially disrupt the
functioning of the public institution of
higher education
so again uh no you can't shout down this
would not protect the shouting down of a
guest speaker
um
so uh one other thing I heard is is that
we're so compliant and then I heard in
the same testimony that we're worried
about lawsuits well I don't understand
if we're so compliant why are we worried
about what's going to happen if we're
doing good then we're doing good
and I don't see any reason to to worry
about about passing this
um
so again I don't think I can necessarily
help on the details I think there are
much better legal Minds in the room than
myself but what I haven't heard from the
committee is an objection to the concept
of protecting free speech so I ask that
if you are able to find little holes
that you can poke in this and you think
a word or two can be changed that you do
the good faith effort to actually make
those changes and not just kind of get
use it as an excuse to get rid of it and
I'll try to answer questions thank you
very much uh represent McDonald
thank you Mr chair and really thank you
for your testimony and to bring
bipartisan legislation forward that's
really important I'm directing my
question to you because you mentioned
that you talk government yeah and a lot
of these speakers that come to campus
they might be associated with a
political party but regardless do you
believe that if they have exposure to
whatever political party it really
doesn't matter it would help them have a
better understanding of government and
what would be taught in your class just
to be exposed to that so just
anecdotally
um again I've already outed myself not
that it was a secret of being a far
leftist but I it's very specifically on
the first day of every semester tell my
students exactly who I am the founder of
the progressive caucus yada yada yada
yada and I say and if you think I'm
being biased at any point call me out
engage with me and every single semester
I will have and apologies if this is
offensive I will have a trump supporting
student and they are almost always
universally a some of my favorite
students because I get to like engage in
like arguments with them and they engage
back but secondly I've had three
separate Trump supporting students that
I didn't change their mind by the end of
it but they told me that I was their
favorite teacher at the school so
because I engaged in these conversations
so
um that
Marketplace of ideas is very important
um I'll just very briefly because the
the whole concept of the First Amendment
and I I apologize if this is patronizing
I'm just going to read the first
amendment really quick Congress shall
make no law respecting an establishment
of religion or prohibiting the free
exercise thereof or Bridging the freedom
of speech or of the press or of the
right of the people to peaceably
assemble and to petition the government
for a redress of grievances and while
that says Congress we have long since
gone through what is called selective
incorporation by saying that also
applies to States
um so I think that
um
original question was about political
parties I think right I'm sorry I went
for your students benefit in
understanding Civics and government and
just being more engaged if these
speakers were allowed to come to the
school yes yeah so uh oh political
speech political speed there's a reason
in
specifically political speech is super
super protected so basically above and
beyond the you know the Supreme Court
has and through all kinds of case law
we've determined there are exceptions to
every single one of our constitutional
rights
um however political free speech is so
fervently defended by the courts because
it is so very important to how we have
government if we give up political Free
Speech we're throwing in the game so yes
it's very important thank you very much
are there further questions from the
committee
representately
Mr chair thank you representative Reed
where was it in here that you said it
was in uh
applied to indoor because I you and so
it doesn't specifically say indoor but
the Roman numeral one so it's line 13
with the second page
um doesn't apply to indoor or outdoor
applied to all forms okay and then it
includes things like guest speakers
which typically are indoors so um it's
not an explicit that's one of those
little tiny holes that if you find that
you know you want to poke a hole in it
then do the work to put something in it
says it includes indoors but
um but yeah I think this is reasonably
interpreted to include everything on
campus
yes thank you I asked the same question
that I asked representative Lynn which
was why this does not apply to private
universities who in I think should also
respect free speech I agree with you
representatively I I personally do agree
with you I think that um representative
Lynn is correct in the assessment that
we're running into murkier Waters when
we talk about what a private institution
can and can't do so you know the
government can't ABR so first amendment
is about what the government can do to
you all of the Constitution is about
what the government can and can't do to
you
um so while we can say state
universities cannot limit your free
speech because of the first amendment I
can't say that you can't limit My Free
Speech if I come over to your house
so I think we should be able to do that
however we're getting into murkier this
is very clear that if it's a state thing
the government can't abridge your speech
but once you're getting into private
situations then it's much murkier and so
I I agree in the the concept but it
would be more difficult to get past
you'd have a lot more people opposing it
any further questions
thank you very much Robertson Lane and
reluct our to that question you had
we've had that many times here Dartmouth
College was formed before we were a
country
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee uh the different face from AFP
here today usually about Sarah so you're
stuck with me uh my name is Ross
Connolly I'm the deputy state director
for Americans for Prosperity here in New
Hampshire here to voice our support for
HB 516
um I'll try to be brief and address some
of the the points that have come up but
uh really but what this discussion
centers around is that free speech is
really the foundational Cornerstone of
any free and open society and University
Systems especially uh are centers of
Higher Learning and and diverse thought
and should be encouraged to to protect
and uphold the free speech of their
students being intellectually curious
organizing groups around a certain idea
are very important principles for for uh
any any Center of Higher Learning and
this bill would stop the practice of
constant change is in student speech
policies from occurring and give
certainty to students that the
legislature is the body that is
protecting their first amendment rights
teaching young people the virtues of
respectful civil debate and disagreement
are absolutely critical in the coming
years as we see in our our political
system the division uh between
disagreeing parties is just becoming
greater and greater and the the solution
to this is is to encourage people to
listen to each other to hear the other
perspective and especially for young
people to understand those that are
coming from a different place
um this bill would simply put in statute
these basic protections for students
First Amendment rights on public
university campuses while still allowing
broad discretion by the university to
protect rights of way on campus and
control uh campus activities what HB 516
does not do it does not allow speech
such as calls to commit violence or
harassment and it also still allows the
institution uh to Halt demonstrations
that are disruptful to campus activities
this small reasonable change would start
the process of moving campuses back to
to being these centers of Higher
Learning questioning uh and critical
thought
uh it's it's no secret that universities
across the country and right here in New
Hampshire are under pressure uh from
both sides of this argument between
those who who want to protect and
preserve free speech and those who are
demanding more and more censorship this
bill is a release valve for the
University system uh it protects
University administrators and employees
by Shifting the burden of of protecting
those speech rights from the University
system to the legislature where you are
all sworn to to uphold these these
principles
um and I'll point out that this bill is
a result uh the the language you see in
front of you is the result of years of
work by this committee and uh by the
Coalition of of folks that have been
working on on this bill from across the
political Spectrum uh in 2021 this
committee provided an incredibly
valuable uh critiques and feedback on on
a similar our bill I believe it was HB
234 at the time
and our Coalition used that feedback uh
to to change the bill make it simpler
and and more address the direct point of
really just protecting those key speech
uh Speech rights for for students on
campus uh so HB 516 as you've seen is
supported by a broad Coalition from
across the political Spectrum uh fire
the First Amendment part Partnerships
Alliance defending Freedom Americans for
Prosperity and the ACLU of New Hampshire
19 States and Counting have have
passed legislation similar to this uh
really protecting these speech speech
rights on public campuses uh including
States from Republican and Democrat
majorities uh and I I will point out I
only know of a handful of lawsuits
across across the entire country that
have actually happened as a result of of
a legislature passing legislation of
this type Free Speech expression and
Association they should be not uh they
should not be partisan issues and uh you
know we believe that this bill would go
a long ways towards really encouraging
students to to talk to one another on
campus and to start to listen to each
other and understand each other so for
all these reasons urge the committee to
move uh HP 516 ought to pass and I'd be
happy it's about the best of my ability
to answer any of your questions thank
you are there questions from the
committee yes representative Miler uh
thank you Mr chair thank you for being
here we've heard today from fire we've
heard from UNH we've heard from Reverend
Mew that there are no problems so are
there currently based upon the work that
was done two years ago in trying to
comply with some of the issues that were
in fact identified
do you have any information that would
contrary those perspectives as far as
access to free speech in this state and
college campuses I think thank you for
the question of Representative uh I I
think it's hard as as previous I can't
remember who which speaker but a
previous uh person testified that it is
hard to identify uh where these these
issues are popping up obviously the Dave
Rubin event was was uh an incident that
went viral uh there's been an incident
in Cinco de Mayo and at UNH uh where
there were similar incidents I can't
really point to anything in particular
but that's really not the purpose of
this bill the purpose is
it's I think it's great and and
commendable that the university system
has has shifted from those speech codes
but I the the first amendment is first
for a reason and uh I think it is of
such importance uh that we as as a state
encourage free speech and especially uh
in in college systems uh that the
legislature uh codify this into law so
that a future administration of of
universities public universities in New
Hampshire does not retract those and we
go backwards uh because that that's
something uh that we believe the
legislature should have a say in thank
you for the questions
thank you very much thank you very much
foreign
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Caleb Dalton I'm
senior counsel with the center for
academic freedom at Alliance defending
Freedom uh just by way of reference so
my defending freedom is a non-profit
legal organization High practice
specifically in the area of academic
freedom my job in essence is to sue
public universities when I violate the
first amendment I I'm kind of the
plaintiff's bar that the university
referred to uh and I'll come at that
from a bit of this perspective my job
here is if I could work myself out a job
that would be great if you guys pass
this bill that would work myself out of
half of the job that I do around the
country and that would be by eliminating
speech zones and permit policies on
University campuses and the securing
free association I had a whole uh
presentation prepared I've kind of
philosophical about the value of free
speech and the marketplace of ideas but
I I think a lot of the speakers have
already covered that and I think it'd be
a waste of this committee's time for me
to rehash why the first amendment is
important I it sounds to me like most of
us all agree that that's the case but
representative mylar you've you've asked
multiple times why do we need this
there's if there's no issues right I'd
like to address that point and also to
respond to a few issues that the
University's Council brought up so
specifically why is this necessary are
there any policies that this would
actually address and and there actually
are uh first I'll note I was contacted
by a student at Keene State University
last year who was directed to the Free
Speech Zone Keen State maintains a free
speech area for outside members
ostensibly under their policy but as a
student he was directed that he had to
speak in that speech Zone I was able to
work with him so that he's no longer on
having to do that but there have been
minor instances here and there but I
also want to address uh the committee's
attention to unh's specific outdoor
assembling events permit policy I
believe the universities Council brought
this up saying oh if it's any event
under 25 you don't have to get a permit
um that's sort of true but the policy
actually says you don't have to have a
permit as long as you don't advertise
your event anywhere including on social
media so this would say you have to have
a permit if just two members or two
students let's say there's two students
on campus and you say hey I I want to go
address this important issue we're gonna
talk about it because it's important in
the news today and you post on Tick Tock
or SnapChat or whatever the the current
social media you say hey guys I'm out
here come join me automatically then you
have to have gotten a permit or you're
in violation of unh's policy right now
so I appreciate that my friends at fire
have given these policies a green light
and I do appreciate I want to reiterate
UNH has some of the best policies I have
seen on distribution of literature and
other issues like that they have done a
great job at at fixing several of those
issues that haven't been there but it's
not perfect and that highlights why this
is necessary because changes in staff
changes an Administration mean changes
in policy
this committee and the and the
legislature if this bill is passed
can level that out so it doesn't matter
whether there's a change in staff or a
change in Personnel or a change in
leadership that the policies remain
stable across the board I can think of
multiple instances right now of cases
where I've actually sued universities
we've won a settlement with a good
policy put in place and then within two
years those policies have been changed
back
because there's changes in Personnel
people forget different staff turnover a
lot of these personal policies are
written by staff or administrators they
may not be familiar with these issues so
that's one of the most important reasons
if the university is already abiding by
these it shouldn't be an issue to codify
this and say look these are the basic
standard principles that every
University should be abiding by and I
would like to address as well just a few
issues that have been brought up by the
committee and and the questions that
have come up
so as to immunity immunity was brought
up several times and I the judge did a
good job clarifying I would like to
clarify just one brief point on that as
well uh the 11th Amendment the text does
say that no you know that is another
citizen right but anybody can't no no
person can sue the state of New
Hampshire or an arm of the state and the
university is an arm of the state right
under the 11th Amendment Mary so I I sue
universities all the time how do I do
that I actually have to sue members of
the Board of Trustees normally for
policies like this right
um so that's what I have to do Under the
Federal Constitution under 1983 what
this waiver of immunity does is allow
for a lawsuit directly against the
university rather than against members
who enforce it the president or the
university Board of Trustees so and it
also allows an under state law whereas
when I'm normally bringing a lawsuit
it's under federal law so that that's
what the immunity waiver does and I I
think it's a good thing to add some
teeth to this to tell the universities
you actually mean it when you say these
are the policies that they should be
adopting uh something was brought up
about violence and Shout Downs I want to
clarify and and I believe the university
said there's some confusion or ambiguity
here and I don't think there really is
and I want to but I've read this
multiple times I'm pretty familiar with
these issues this does not apply at all
to classroom issues classroom issues
have been a are a problem and when there
are you know professors who don't have
that excellent you know ethic that we
just heard that has been an issue in
classrooms this bill doesn't address
that at all
it doesn't Address speech in classrooms
that's that's not what this bill
addresses shout Downs this does not
create a cause of action for a student
to sue over being censored or a speaker
it doesn't create a cause of action for
that but what it does make very clear
is that shout Downs are not protected
speech under this bill so if you're
blocking access physically blocking
access threatening violence against a
speaker that's not protected speech
that's what this portion does so it
basically makes it very clear
universities can apply their policies to
against protesters who are actually
restricting other people's ability to
have free speech as well so but it
doesn't create a cause of action and
specifically restrict that if that makes
sense so those I just want to clarify
those two ambiguities
the university said this could raise the
cost of litigation I don't think that's
actually the case in fact I think it
could lower the potential liability to
the state if the universities look at
these requirements and they abide by
them
then they are going to be much less
likely to be sued if they don't abide by
them then it could be the fact that I
have to come and Sue the university
under 1983 under the First Amendment and
get attorney's fees there so I don't
think that there's any increased cost to
the university system or the state
bypassing this bill all it does is give
teeth to Common Sense principles that
the university should be abiding by
anyway
I think those are the primary issues
that I seemed like this uh this
committee had questions with I'm happy
to answer any questions if you have so
can you clarify something for me then
um when I'm looking at definition on
campus here it talks about Campus
Community it talks about outdoor areas
of Campus so immediately my mind says
well there must be indoor areas to
campus as well
so do you see the statement on line 20
6 27 page two
as providing this bill some ambiguity in
terms of nothing in this section shall
be interpreted as limiting the right of
student expression Elsewhere on campus
Are We Now talking into our campus
oh and I so any bill that says nothing
in this shall reinterpreted to limit the
rights elsewhere so if it's all that
means is when we say you're allowed to
speak Outdoors
we're not saying you're not allowed to
speak indoors we're just not speaking to
it so this legislation just does not
speak to indoor expression if that makes
sense
Kelly
good afternoon
thank you so much for hosting this Mr
chair and miss and members of the
committee I'm going to try to keep this
quick because I know it's been a long
day for you guys
um my name is Kelly McLean I'm
presenting on behalf of first Liberty
Institute we are the nation's largest
Law Firm dedicated exclusively to BR to
defending and restoring religious
liberty for all Americans
we represent Jeffrey ozanne and Gabby
ospina who you will be hearing from a
little bit later
and the other student leaders of the
free exercise Coalition or the FEC at
the University of New Hampshire Franklin
Pierce School of Law also known as unh
most of my testimony a lot of you have
asked you know is this something that
keeps happening how like is this
something that needs to be addressed so
hopefully my testimony and theirs will
um as my clients will explain
last November the group applied to
establish its inaugural campus location
however instead of administratively
approving the student group the law
school student Bar Association tabled
its application after publicly
questioning its sincere the sincerity of
its members religious beliefs
first Liberty sent a demand letter
explaining why the school's decision was
unconstitutional
almost two months after the SBA meeting
our clients the FEC were granted
official recognition as a student group
but not by the SBA the SBA refused to
act and deferred to the UNH law
administration instead
this is not the type of tolerance or
free inquiry anyone should expect at one
of our nation's law schools
like our senior Council Jeremy dyes said
it is simply inexcusable and
unconstitutional for any University to
hold itself out as tolerant diverse and
welcoming
but then exclude students because of
their religious viewpoint
federal law makes clear that it is
unlawful to discriminate against
organizations and individuals on the
basis of religion
UNH law failed its duty to the
constitution in protecting the civil
rights of the FEC instead treated their
religious beliefs with content public
scorn and hostility
it has settled law that the First
Amendment rights of speech and
Association extend to campuses of state
universities widmar V Benson
in this case and several others the
course upheld the students at American
universities are entitled to express
their beliefs on campus as well as by
associate with students that share those
beliefs
is the responsibility of a State
University to ensure that students
wishing to associate receive even-handed
treatment under university leadership
schools like UNH often fail to
understand the seriousness of their
actions and refuse to recognize the
liability that these actions place on
the School faculty and staff
just within the past two years two
federal circuit courts of appeal and one
Federal District Court rejected
qualified immunity defenses and imposed
personal liability on University
officials whose actions affirmed the
same level of intolerance and hostility
towards religion on display at UNH law
it should not take a demand letter for
UNH law SBA to comply with obligations
of the U.S Constitution
to respect religious organization's
presence and its speech on campus
in conclusion public colleges and
universities are bound by the free
exercise clause of the First Amendment
and cannot base their policy decisions
on hostility towards religion or desire
to exclude a religious viewpoint
which to which they disagree
while the law is clear cases like fecs
keep happening
I hope you will carefully consider HB
516 and any bill that points back to the
protections of free speech and
Association laid out in our first
amendment
I will submit my written testimony I
think you have it in front of you also
in front of you is our demand letter to
UNH law this includes all the settled
law I referenced in my testimony plus
several others
um thank you for your time I'm happy to
answer any questions you may have thank
you are there questions from the
committee
thank you thank you so much
like to invite Jeff
Roseanne is this oza
I was in yep
welcome
hello Mr chairman Vice chairman and
members of the committee my name is Jeff
ozan and I'm currently a hybrid JD
student at UNH law and the president of
the free exercise Coalition or FEC last
year a group of law school students and
myself started FEC so that our religious
beliefs and those of other students may
be better represented on campus we built
our organization with one goal to equip
and enable the religious student in
sharing their beliefs in this Melting
Pot we call Law School we believe that a
public law school should have a healthy
balance of perspectives something we
thought was missing on our campus to do
so we created FPC to be run by
like-minded Believers unashamed of
sharing our beliefs and willing to equip
religious students of all Creeds to do
the same these student leaders of FEC
created and publicly subscribed to a
statement of our beliefs that ensured
that the organization has run consistent
with this founding and certain canons of
interpretation this statement embodies a
very expression of religion we thought
could be a better exercise on campus
Deputy board believes that it is okay
for law school students to have
traditional Christian values and we
believe that it is legal and yes
necessary to share these values during
our law school experience for instance I
personally believe that our creator
wishes to spend
eternity with each and every person I
believe that our sin separates us from
our creator so our creator sent his one
and only son to die and atone for our
sins through faith in this love that the
Son of God Jesus Christ died and rose
again for our sins women be granted the
free gift of eternal life of our crater
and I knew I would do that there but uh
now for the free exercise coalition to
be a working student organization on
campus we had to pursue affiliation
through the student Board Association or
the SBA
prior to the SBA meeting to recognize
our affiliation we submitted an
application which included information
about our organization including the
statement of our beliefs from the start
of the SBA affiliation meeting it was
clear that our statement of police was
an issue for the SBA the SBA spent
nearly an hour inquiring about the
specifics of our beliefs this SBA in
concert with our fellow law school
students didn't stop him aligning just
our beliefs and organization they went
so far to personally attack us for
holding those beliefs for instance we
were publicly shamed and labeled hateful
bigots oppressors for sharing what we
believe about God's truth even after the
Christian legal Society had admonished
the same SBA just a couple months prior
for attacking their religious police the
space still used the content of our
religious beliefs as basis to refuse the
affiliation of our franchise Coalition
it even appears that in the wake of
religious student organizations our own
law school has been seeking to implement
an all-commerce policy which would
pretextually ban any student
organization that requires its
leadership to subscribe to a statement
of beliefs like every faith-based group
these actions by the law school and its
SBA show up fundamental disregard for
the First Amendment and the policies at
play in every Public University FEC knew
that our religious beliefs would not be
widely accepted in the halls of modern
Academia that is exactly why we believe
our organization is important however
what FTC did not expect is that a law
school and a students could be so
uninformed on the protections of the
First Amendment
not knowing where to turn the frick size
Coalition reached out to the first
Liberty Institute a non-profit Law Firm
concerned with religious liberty for all
charging nothing first Liberty came in
and defended our right to exist and be a
useful contributor to the ideas on
campus at our next affiliation meeting
the SBA our peers once again refused to
vote on our affiliation a continued and
tacit disapproval of our existence
instead the law school administration
now informed of the first amendment by
first Liberty took over and did what the
SBA refused to do approve the free
exercise Coalition as a UNH lawsuit
organization
I wish I could end this testimony here
however it seems every step forward by
FEC is resisted for instance during the
turmoil of our affiliation we
inexplicably lost our faculty advisor a
necessary prerequisite to affiliation
UNH law has not yet appointed a faculty
advisor for FEC that is willing to
assist and advocate for our group
moreover the free excise Coalition and
the Christian legal Society has joined
together to offer the Christian students
a symbol that they are indeed accepted
as an important part of campus life we
have requested to hang the Christian
flag on campus just as other students
and Civic groups have hung Flags
supporting their causes for instance
cultural art cultural art displays black
history displays the pride flag have all
hung on campus and been displayed on
campus for Years yet when we request to
display this religious symbol the law
school continues to delay and inform us
that quote unquote this request provides
an opportunity for our law school to
formalize a policy with respect to the
display of flags at the law school while
numerous displays of other social and
Civic groups are exhibited ours is slow
walked in nored and sidelined we're
simply asking that we be treated like
other students and student groups on
campus
to conclude intentionally or not UNH law
has made us feel marginalized as
students centering religious viewpoints
from even entering student conversation
if your traditional Christian on campus
you must not share your beliefs let
alone operate a student organization
consistent with those beliefs lest you
be viciously attacked and ostracized and
potentially worse maybe your existence
as a religious student on campus will
spur the law school to create a new
General application policy to limit your
freedom of expression there's much work
to be done to educate New Hampshire's
law school and students about the extent
of the First Amendment this Marketplace
of ideas and religions placed in the
conversation the pre-exis Coalition
exists for such a purpose and we hope
the New Hampshire legislature will
carefully consider the free speech and
Association protections of HB 516 could
offer to FEC and future students at UNH
law thank you for your time and
attention to this important matter I'm
happy to try to answer any questions you
may have
thank you very much are there any
questions from the committee
Gabriella
good afternoon Mr chair and members of
the committee
my testimony is brief
my name is Gabby ospina I'm a second
year hybrid JD student at UNH law
I'm the treasurer of the free exercise
coalition
and I'm a devout Catholic
last November Jeff approached me with
the idea of starting a group at the law
school with the mission of advocating
for and protecting religious Liberties
on campus
our Law School
and in fact I
could have really used a group like this
as a Catholic holy week is the most
important week of the year even more so
than the Christmas season every day has
a purpose and a religious practice to
participate in in preparation for Easter
Sunday
that week is the culmination of 40 days
of intentional fasting praying and
almsgiving
it is a spiritually transformative week
that I missed out on on my first year of
law school because I didn't know who or
how to ask for a religious accommodation
in my classes or even if I could
I was scared of anyone knowing who I am
and what I believe in
I was scared of being judged for my
beliefs
and because of that fear and isolation I
struggled during Holy Week to balance my
religious practices with my academic
responsibilities
so when Jeff approached me with the idea
of forming this group I saw very clearly
a space in our law school where the
group could help its students like me to
avoid fear and isolation
within a week we had a name the free
exercise Coalition a mission to protect
and defend religious Liberties and we
also included a statement of faith for
board members an essential component to
ensure that the leadership of the group
would truly protect even the most
unpopular religious beliefs
we submitted the application to the SBA
I'm aware that my religious beliefs are
bold and that people disagree with me as
is their right to
but I never imagined we would be treated
the way that we were at the SBA
affiliation meeting
um by law students and by faculty of the
law school we were interrogated about
our statement of faith
called bigots oppressors
and a problem the university needs to
the problem that is what I am all they
knew about us was a short list of our
shared religious beliefs and that was
sufficient evidence to label me a
problem
but what truly hurt in that moment was
that at the end of the meeting my
associate Dean apologized to the
students who had spent the last 30
minutes disparaging our character
up until that moment I had experienced
only kindness and support from the
University
while I experienced medical issues that
they were supportive when my grandfather
passed away during finals week of my
first semester of Law School
and it was very difficult to feel that
support ripped out from underneath me in
that moment when I needed it the most
thank you for considering this bill and
anything that clarifies and points back
to the First Amendment and freedom
of religious expression thank you for
your time and I'm happy to answer any
questions thank you are there any
questions from the committee
representative miler thank you Mr chair
and thank you for sharing your story
both you and Mr ozing talked about a
hybrid student could you define what is
a hybrid student yes so the hybrid JD
program at UNH Franklin Pierce School of
Law is one of four ABA accredited hybrid
programs basically we're able to stay
outside of the state living outside of
the state while taking courses
asynchronously and also we are obligated
to come in person to UNH to take
in-person classes
further questions from the committee
yes represent Damon
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
could you just give us a little more
what uh what faiths are represented in
the pre-exercise Coalition and what the
statement of faith is yeah the statement
of faith
um we decided to keep it as a
judeo-christian values that represented
a wider range of beliefs while also kind
of consolidating what everyone has
shared in what was your first question
again
I think you may have just answered it
was what faiths are represented in your
organization oh okay yes and that just
to be clear that is just for board
members but any faiths any person is
allowed to
um seek the services that we offer or
participate in in the in the uh in the
group
for the questions
yes representative Woodcock thank you
chairman good afternoon thank you for
being here
um I'm sure it's not easy to come in and
um how many uh students are in your
organization
uh currently we have
five uh board members okay that's that's
the entity of the group yes okay thank
you thank you chairman you're welcome
further questions
thank you very much thank you
and the last bank card I have is Lance
Kinser
you won the lottery
well those are those last two witnesses
are are tough acts to follow yes uh my
name is Lance Kinser I am here on behalf
of First Amendment partnership we uh
have the privilege to work with some of
the nation's largest Faith communities
with respect to their common commitment
to First Amendment freedoms and I I
don't say this is a matter of undue
flattery that I have an opportunity to
testify across the country and uh spent
10 years in a state legislature myself
and I will say both the the way in which
this uh this hearing's been conducted
the quality of the witnesses and the
quality of the questions uh it's not
what you see everywhere so I'm really
it's been exciting to be here and a
privilege I'm going to try to direct my
question my comments to a few things
that have arisen
um that I think might be helpful one of
the questions of why this might be
needed in New Hampshire was answered in
part by I think the the prior to folks
who spoke but I will say I was very
involved in Iowa in passage of similar
legislation in 2019 and there's been
some brief reference to a situation at
the University of Iowa that arose that
resulted in some uh some judgments and
ultimately there were two cases decided
at the eighth Court Circuit Court of
Appeals in 2021 that ultimately between
the two cases resulted in a two million
dollar judgment against the university
ultimately paid by taxpayers in that
instance the eighth circuit determined
that there was not qualified immunity
for the University officials who had
violated the associational rights of
student groups on campus the university
ultimately indemnified them and so did
pay but they were found individually
liable for their conduct and what
happened there it was Viewpoint
discrimination along exactly the lines
that are being talked about here there
was a tiny Evangelical campus ministry
about 10 members that was told that
because they had standard they required
their board members to sign a statement
of faith that they were excluded from
con from being on campus the university
when they were called to account with
respect to that by a district court
judge said well the way we can be equal
is to kick all the religious groups off
campus so Muslim groups sneak groups
they were all kicked off campus for a
period of time it went back to the same
district court judge as you can imagine
was not amused and but in the midst of
this and this is really my point that
all started in 2017. it was 2019 when
the legislature passed and the governor
signed a clarifying Bill to try to make
sure that this didn't happen again in
Iowa but I can guarantee you that when
the Judgment ultimately came down in 21
uh they wish they would have passed that
bill in 16 or 17 and not have waited to
19 until they were in the midst of a
controversy uh my my strong belief and
this particular associational rights
language has been passed in 17 States at
this point and my belief is that Clarity
on this issue a relatively simple
straightforward portion of the bill is
conflict reducing it prevents litigation
that should never happen in the first
place no University student no Student
Association should ever have to sue
their own University simply to associate
around common ideas in fact the ability
to assemble to associate along common
ideas and to do so without
uh any kind of uh attempt by the
university to say certain ideas are
approved and certain ideas are not
approved goes to the core from my
perspective of teaching the values of
pluralism that universities are all
about having diverse student clubs is a
good to the University's Mission but I
guess the point I want to make because
so much of what I was intending to say
had been said already was just to kind
of close with this the law is very clear
in this area there are cases going back
50 years and it's interesting one of the
the prior people who testified talked
about how in the early in the 60s and
70s it was left-wing groups that were
winning Heely be James a case in 1972
that said that student groups can't be
denied recognition by a public
university because of their beliefs was
the case involving the students for a
Democratic Society their National
Organization called for the violent
overthrow of the government of the
United States but because their local
chapter did not had not taken any
affirmative action to engage in violence
of any kind had only been peaceful in
protesting the Vietnam War and other
things that they were opposed to the U.S
Supreme Court in Healey said they have
to be recognized the Whitmer V Vincent
case that came about a decade after that
said that belief-based student groups
must be provided access to facilities
under the same standards as other groups
and then in 1995 A Student Activity fee
funds which is an issue that has come up
cannot be withheld from a group merely
because they promote or manifest a
particular belief system that's
Rosenberger V Virginia and my view is
this I think especially post those two
eighth circuit opinions in involving the
University of Iowa I think
administrators are starting to get it
but what you've heard here is that
oftentimes where the conflict is
happening now is it the student
government or student Bar Association
level a lot of times those students
aren't well informed of the latest case
law involving the First Amendment and
one thing that I know in Iowa is that
they've begun instructing student
government it's there in their very
clear simple straightforward law with
respect to Student Association so that
when before student governments meet to
make these decisions they're informed
this is what the Constitution says this
is what Iowa law says and it's not
conflict creating its conflict reducing
so I think that New Hampshire would do
well to pass this legislation I think
that locking in clear protections that
are consistent with what the first
amendment has long been understood to
mean is promoted of First Amendment
values but it's also promotive of
Civility on campus and conflict reducing
so I think the the committee for your
time I'd be pleased to answer any
questions and just it's been fun to be
here first do you have do you have
written testimony there so I have a
I have a pretty big packet of info that
I thought would be cumbersome to hand
out but I'll like set it up here
afterwards and anybody who wants to take
one of my packets that would be great I
would love you too but it's a little
bulky okay I do have a question for you
yes um we have a definition of student
organization here what it means and
officially recognized group
by whom what's the criteria that you use
to recognize groups in your experience
out in Iowa when you have an association
uh and then you mentioned that
Administration may get it
but down underneath folks are not
getting it so universities it's
commonplace for universities to have a a
process through kind of a student life
section of the University that deals
with campus organizations and normally
there are some requirements like you
have to submit a constitution that talks
about what your rules and bylaws are you
have to have a faculty sponsor you have
to have sometimes a certain number of
members and it's very often the case it
depends upon the university but in many
instances those applications first do go
to a student Bar Association or a
student government Association depending
upon whether it's law school or
undergrad and so then they meet and do
the approvals and really those approvals
should never in any way relate to the
Viewpoint of the group it should all
really be whether they just meet those
basic criteria and candidly as an
opportunity for those groups to kind of
present make sure they're known by the
student organizations and then you'll
have you know kind of a club day a
recruitment day at the outset and then
they get benefit to communication but
what what happens many times then
is that if there is a controversy
ultimately the university itself has the
authority to step in and
um veto a decision by the student body
Association but oftentimes that takes a
significant amount of time to occur and
what I would say is this you know the
faith-based groups that we work with
um the fact that you know these big
money judgments are not what they want
uh they just want to to serve and
disciple and be places for community and
so if you're a kid who's been working in
you know a campus ministry for several
years you get your senior year you're
going to be the president and the campus
group set and the university says no
you're not recognized well by the time
you go down figure out as a kid who who
do I contact they go to Federal Court
you sort through what the facts are a
couple months later down the line you
get a piece of paper from a federal
court judge saying you know what they
didn't do what they should have done
well you're several months of your
relatively short senior year of child
knowledge your activity has been
significantly interrupted oftentimes
you've been drugged through the mud and
campus newspapers and other things so
it's best even though most of the groups
that I'm working with if they litigate
they're going to win under existing law
but what they want is not to have to
litigate and what we've seen in the
states that have passed these is that
when the standard is clear it's less
likely that there'll be litigation to
begin with and that's good for everybody
thank you further questions from the
committee yes represent luno so thank
you very much Mr chair and thank you
very much Mr Kinser for for joining us
this afternoon and I absolutely agree
with the with your your your very very
first uh comments that I think this has
been a very respectful discussion and I
think very much a learning experience
I'm certainly speaking from my uh
perspective but I think
for everybody here and and I also want
to want to extend that comment to um to
the the students from UNH law
um uh uh Jeff ozan and Gabriella Spina
who I think spoke very very well
um about the situations that they're
facing there and I don't want my my
question here to in any way be
interpreted as an assumption or an
aspersion of of
of what their organization done and what
their beliefs are I think we can just
sort of take it at a very generic
um you know sort of a
non-specific level sure but um but but
specifically
um every organ every Institute of higher
education that I have involvement with
right now I'm on I'm on three University
boards
um have a mission statement and core
values and and every one of these and
it's probably many many many many more
um one of those core values
um uh is a is a is a strong sense of
diversity Equity inclusion and Justice
and and I'm just trying to better
understand how
how
um some of these things whether they're
student groups student organizations
that are failing to be recognized
um
um how that can coexist with with the
core values that um that a
post-secondary institution you know has
and uh and where where does that line
get get drawn and I think it's very
similar to where's the money up here
right that's what true sure so if I
understand the the question I mean my
view would be that recognizing
um student groups on a Viewpoint neutral
basis is not only what the law already
requires it's promotive of diversity
equity and inclusion and that
um it's never been viewed as
discrimination okay say federal civil
rights law and I'm thinking of
faith-based groups here in particular
for a faith-based group to say only
people who share our faith can teach our
message so generally speaking religious
discrimination is illegal but if a
church wants to say we're only going to
hire as a pastor someone who shares our
theological beliefs that's
discriminating in a sense based upon
religion they're hiring somebody and
they're using religion as criteria but
it's always been understood that within
the context of a belief-based
organization it's actually not
discriminatory for religious groups to
use religious criteria in saying who
gets to speak our message rather that's
actually promotive of freedom and so my
view is that the way that you promote
diversity equity and inclusion on campus
is not by saying certain kinds of ideas
that groups may have are off limits and
won't be allowed rather we make sure as
this bill does the groups regardless of
viewpoint are clearly protected and so
even though I think sometimes this issue
gets tied up in in concerns about
whether
there are groups that maybe differ on
Dei issues and they're being recognized
I think the broader concept of Dei is
actually promoted by having a diversity
of views of course those views have to
be expressed respectfully no one should
be harassed there should be no illegal
conduct I think the bill does a good job
of giving the university all the tools
they need to make sure that that respect
that you're understandably concerned
about is there but it also makes sure
that we avoid litigation and that we we
model for students in these policies
respect for a diversity of viewpoints
that'll be my own view on that I'll
follow up to that thank you and that
that your answer helps me a lot on on
this and so just to sort of push on on
on you know where does it get muddy
where does that Line in the Sand get
drawn and um and referring back to what
representative Lynn was talking about
earlier
um outside uh where outside Chicago and
um and you know so I'm getting specific
here but but
um
Jeff lausanne mentioned about about a um
not being able to to uh to display a
flag let's say in the entry hall at UNH
law I don't know where where where the
display would be and I'm not again not
casting any assumptions or aspersions on
anything but but if if such a request
was was so offensive in the way that
Judge Lynn had talked about would would
that be something that the university
would have to comply with and allow to
have happen or can they can they
actually draw the line somewhere yeah so
first I'll say and I don't mean this is
a cop-out that my area of particular
specialty is more on the associational
rights and so I don't want to get out
over my skis because there's some
smarter folks than me behind me on some
of these issues but I would say uh that
from my perspective once you establish
that we're going to allow particular
kind we're going to allow this to be a a
public forum or a limited public forum
sometimes the the language that she is
once that decision is made then the
Viewpoint discrimination decision has
already kind of you've kind of defaulted
on the you know the Viewpoint
Viewpoint discrimination decision
already because one of the things that
you absolutely can't do once you have a
limited public forum is discriminate
based upon Viewpoint now there may be
instances where for example in the
context of a particular classroom where
you could argue well this isn't a a
limited public forum we don't just allow
people you know off the street to come
in and express their views on whatever
you know in the middle of a math class
but if the university has a policy of
saying there are certain places within
the University where groups are free to
display Flags then it's a very dicey
thing not just into the context of this
bill but I think under the First
Amendment for the University to then say
we're going to discriminate based upon
Viewpoint that's pretty black letter
constitutional law yeah it is
representative cardelli oh thank you
what I'm hearing is that possibly in
from your experience in some of the
instances you've come across it seems
like maybe a narrower version of Dei
policy rather than the broader view that
you just mentioned has bumped up against
associations religious associations
trying to start up would that be an
accurate uh characterization that's an
interesting way to think about it I
hadn't quite thought about it I was kind
of thinking out loud as I was giving you
know that that answer but I do think
that the idea that diversity equity and
inclusion
broadly construed is something that I
think we should all be able to agree to
especially in the context of University
campus as long as that
diversity Equity inclusion is promotive
of civil conversation and speech and not
having Viewpoint discrimination I think
when it IT flips and becomes a way of
narrowing discourse and saying certain
ideas are off the table just to begin
with even if Express civilly that's
where there's a problem at least from my
point of view thank you
yes representative Woodcock thank you
chairman good afternoon I'm sure you're
happy to be here on a Friday afternoon
yeah yeah
um but in all seriousness
as representative little said and saw
this before that I've been amazed at the
information uh that I've heard and some
of my some of my thinkings altered
um my first we first began I heard I was
saying free speeches beats and now we're
talking at the end of the day very small
face-based group and a university
organization uh so my question is the
only uh
group person represented we've heard
this afternoon who is opposed to this
but the University of New Hampshire
system
and I'm wondering in your thinking what
it is
well I don't want to speak for anyone
else
um I will say that it's not uncommon
when bills like this are heard for
universities either to not weigh in at
all or or to be supportive so but this
isn't the first time that I've testified
in a place where the universities have
expressed concern I think there's an
understandable desire for universities
to want to control and I don't mean that
at any kind of a negative way to have
flexibility with respect to the policies
that they Implement and so there's a
natural tendency to feel that if a
statute is enacted in this area it may
you know maybe it's not contemplating
some circumstance and then we're going
to be unduly constrained and so I'm
trying to be you know fair with respect
to what their concerns might be I
honestly believe
that the the language that's in this
bill has been subject to sufficient
interpretive work by courts that I don't
think it's going to lead to a lot of
confusion and I'll just kind of in the
answer I guess with this there have been
a number of states but one in which I
can think of in particular and I won't
call out the university but a university
came and testified
um against a bill with some similar
concerns that were heard here and then
about a year later I was told by the
sponsor of the bill you know the
lobbyist for XYZ University came back
and said you know we oppose that bill
but we we kind of like
um when student groups come to us and
say why is this group we don't like why
do they you know get to be on campus
well go complain to your legislator they
told us that you know we we had to do
this that it was it was actually nice
from their perspective to just have a
clear standard in law they could point
to because it's probably no fun for the
universities to be juggling these you
know competing claims of student groups
that don't like each other so that's one
thought that's fine president I have a
smaller question smaller question yes
sir thank you I think thank you um the
last question at least for me thank you
uh once again
we've heard this afternoon the 16th and
we're very 17 and so somewhere there in
that nut range of states that have
supported and participated and have uh
enacted something similar to this is
there what about the other state so why
is that not happening so when I use in
your opinion yeah when I use 17 those
are states that have passed particularly
associational protections and some
states have done that as Standalone
bills other states have done that in the
context of bills that deal with other
speech issues like this one
um you know there are a variety of
reasons I think if I was going to say
number one it is the
do we have an existing problem here and
if not is this an area that we should
really legislate in I think some of the
other concerns that have been expressed
about whether
um
having tight standards at the state
level reduces University flexibility to
decide where some of these lines are
with the questions that were were asked
earlier that may be a reason but I think
more than anything else
um it's just hard to get bills through
the political process I mean when I
started working on this I was looking I
was testifying in Missouri
um you know a couple days ago and I've
been they've been working on this for a
number of years and when I first
testified there on this in 2017 I was
telling them they could be the eighth
state to do this if they would pass it
and I had to change my notes and put a
one you know I said you could be the
18th State and so that's actually quite
a bit of legislative activity over just
the last few years in this area so I
think that there is
um a increasing understanding of the
importance of this and I will say it's
increasingly bipartisan so last year
Indiana passed a very similar Bill and
it actually passed unanimously I think
maybe through both Chambers but at least
unanimously through one chamber and with
substantial bypartisan support you know
Governor Edwards signed a build out of
Louisiana Democratic governor some more
so some of the concern that you know
these were
conservative groups that you know were
were concerned that they're the ones
whose Ox is being gored right now
um I think with a little bit more
perspective people have realized as the
as the representative said previously
ultimately
everybody is at risk if we don't have
clear standards and so left and right I
think our there's more bipartisan
support in the last few years and that's
why it's been increasing but we've got
work to do thank you and thank you if
you can thank you thank you further
questions from the committee not seeing
it one more question last one represent
Balboni
um thank you chair a lot and thank you
and I hope it is a quick question um you
said that 17 states have passed this
legislation
um I'm curious about the number of
lawsuits that might have been brought
since the legislation occurred yeah and
so again to be clear I'm just talking
about the associational portion there
are 17 states there are a few more that
have passed additional protections to be
honest with you I'm not aware
um I'm aware of many cases where in the
context of demand letters or
conversations that attorneys have had
with University general counsel where
these laws have been used as a a basis
for kind of reaching resolution before
the litigation stage but I honestly
don't know that there's a there may have
been a you know I don't think there's
I'm not aware of a single like State
Appellate Court opinion on one of these
associational rights cases and one of
the folks behind me can correct me if
I'm wrong so I just don't think they're
very generative of litigation I think
they're more preventative than anything
thank you thank you very much and we're
going to close this hearing down at this
we're gonna take a
stand-up break here let's have about 10
minutes so we we can have that and we'll
come back and we'll take care of the
last hearing that this education
committee will have this session
teachers cheers oh I just wanted to I
just took all my stuff out of it I
didn't save the blue vanilla
foreign
okay we're gonna go ahead with the last
bill for today it's HP 451 relative to
the State Board of Education prohibition
on discrimination and I welcome Steve
woodcock
having a chair it's a representative
chair of the lad
on behalf of Representative Tana I'm
introducing this bill uh it's
interesting that we just heard for
almost two hours about diversity equity
and inclusion how appropriate
um and I'll read from her text and leave
it it's only three paragraphs if I'm a
representative in schools discrimination
can make it difficult for students to
learn because they don't feel safer
accepted
discrimination in schools contribute to
high rates of absenteeism dropping out
adverse Health consequences academic
underachievement and bullying
every student
has a right to an education free from
discrimination
all students
all students deserve Equitable
opportunities to learn
currently students are protected by
federal laws which cover race color
national origin sex and disability
in New Hampshire we've taken a stand as
a state for recognizing and including
gender identity secular orientation
mental and physical disability and on
non-discrimination laws
RSA 354a New Hampshire
non-discrimination statute causes
employment housing and place the public
accommodations
this bill 451 is simple
it places the New Hampshire
non-discrimination Protections in
addition to the federal
anti-discrimination laws into the
education statutes under 1933
a school Venda or Educational Service in
our state that accepts public funds will
fall under these non-discrimination laws
where taxpayers resourced Public Funding
goes public accountability must follow
and the discrimination are wrong it can
be helpful to those involved
discrimination has had a long history
in our schools fighting discrimination
takes courage and commitment but when we
stand up to injustices and sink Equity
all students stand to benefit
so please join me in voting and
supporting HB 451 I offer that on behalf
of Representative Tanner
thank you
I'd be happy to take any questions but
be equally happy not to
are there any questions representative
cordelli thank you
um thank you for presenting the last
bill
um
legislation
would a let's say a private Christian
School be required to hire a teacher or
a professor
who did not agree with their beliefs
I do not know the answer to that
further questions representative dry
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
Linda representative Tanner's substitute
um I was looking at the same 354-a
um and colon 27 talks about the
opportunity for public education without
discrimination a civil right
it's in here about education it's also
in Colon 29 right to freedom from
discrimination in public workplaces and
education I I believe this is already
covered why are we doing it in the
education things it's already in the
state commission for human rights
chapter
my understanding of the representative
just agrees with that opinion
is that sorry but she disagrees it's
always instead already in statute wants
okay just try to remember that that's
not represent a Tanner out there
and and I don't think anybody can speak
on behalf of Representative Tanner when
you know we're not in representative
Tanner's base so our head so
try to address you know questions which
are not really something that she has to
answer
thank you very much thank you chairman I
what were the two things you've never
housed
the red lights
and put the microphone on so you can
hear me I'm pleased to be here talking
and I'm pleased you can hear me now the
microphone's on
um I am here in support of hb451 I liked
uh hearing from representative Woodcock
the summary that where Public Funding
goes public accountability must follow
when I read this bill I saw it as a way
of addressing the fact that we have
public tax money going out through
vouchers to various private schools and
different educational vendors so for
that reason I really appreciate the
thought of these non-discrimination
policies following that money so that
students can't be discriminated against
by any private school online program or
educational vendor you know that is
taking that tax money
um as you know I've made no secret of it
um I I do not think that the voucher
program we have was very well conceived
I will not dwell on that because you've
you know one thing that we are really
concerned about is that vouchers are
often used end up having the effect of
discriminating against students
public schools are open to all they
serve all students but private schools
and programs can deny students admission
or discipline or expel them for any
number of reasons including disability
sexual orientation or religion and we
want to make sure that
a program that is using public tax money
is not allowed to discriminate against
students
based on disability sexual orientation
religion or any of these protected
categories that are mentioned in the
bill
there are examples across the country of
how private voucher-funded schools have
discriminated from children's with
disability in Texas was rejected by 13
different private schools to a Florida
school that received 1.6 million in
voucher funding in just one year but
tell parents it would kick out gay or
transgendered students
especially troubling is how private
school voucher programs Perpetual
perpetuate racial segregation data going
back more than 10 years show that
vouchers disroportionately serve white
students leaving students of color
behind in schools that become
increasingly more segregated
sadly segregation is baked into vouchers
history budget program started in the
south
they were first created to allow white
students to fund segregation academies
in the wake of Brown versus Board of
Education I know I often come here and
voice positions that some of you don't
agree with but I hope we can all agree
that in New Hampshire we should not be
spending taxpayer money
to
let
um
do like discrimination or segregation
any form including private schools and
programs that don't take certain
students
um
but public might be used that way
through vouchers so I urge you to
support HB 451.
thank you I was trying to summarize
thank you thank you in light of the late
hours are any any questions from the
committee representative cordelli yes
thank you uh thank you for maybe being
our last uh testifier of the day no no
that's okay sorry I tried yep
um
um how about
Public Schools
who accept
a student but they cannot meet their
special needs so have to place them in
sometimes and out of state
facility
um is that discrimination on the basis
of of the public school
no it's not because you are still
providing the student with what they
need and indeed the district is still
paying the cost
so
you are making all the arrangements for
the student
often you have tried what you can within
the you know Staffing facilities that
you have and found that that does not
meet the students need so then you you
find the placement outside
um so the more specialized placement
um to to meet the students needs such as
you know sending them to a specialized
School for students with hearing
impairment or or blindness which is one
then you're also paying for the cost
it's not discrimination if that is what
the team that is working with the
student
in partnership with the parent has
agreed
is the correct
placement for that student that is
called the IEP process
well yes you may yeah
um thank you
um so I'm not sure how that differs from
a student going to a private school that
maybe does not have the facilities to
meet their special needs but provides
them with other options and suggestions
um isn't that being
really more helpful to the student
rather than accepting them into the
school
taking their tuition money knowing that
they cannot really meet the needs of
that student well in the first situation
the public school has not turned the
student away this public school is still
actively working with the student and
the family indeed underwriting the cost
of what the student needs in the second
situation the private school has just
said we've got some suggestions for you
but that's all we are obligated to do
so there's a difference
further questions from the committee yes
thank you Mr chairman I kind of answered
my old question because I find that this
bill is taking things a little further
and expanding everything that I talked
about before as being not just public
school but other things a longer list
but I would my question to you is how
does an online program or an educational
if it refuses to serve them that is one
way it could discriminate against a
student
um you know based on the categories
mentioned in the bill
you know because we we both take them
yes I kind of think of online programs
something that I buy and use or an
educational vendors something I buy
material from and use I don't see the
thing an online program could be
something you need to sign up for when
you're actively participating in so
um
not mutually exclusive definitions uh
you you sign up and you are
participating in
thank you further representative
cordelli and then representative
uh thank you um maybe you might have an
answer for the question
um I asked earlier about uh let's say a
Christian School
um would they be required under this
um legislation if passed
to hire a teacher who did not believe in
their faith
yeah I was looking at this mainly from
the point of view of how it applied to
students so I gotta say I'm not a lawyer
so um I'm going to pass on that web you
can ask representative Tanner when she
is back thank you okay representative
now thank you Mr chair and thank you for
um I'm confused because you said that an
online program is something you sign up
for I would
put the EFA program in that same
categories the parents are signing up
for and then choosing
what
how to use those funds in order to best
serve their students needs
it's still it's still coming out of the
the public taxes though I mean you still
underwriting
any further questions from the committee
thank you very much
[Music]
good afternoon Mr chairman and committee
members thank you for having me
um and I wish you all a very good week
next week with your week off thank you
so I think this is a great bill and I
support it for the basic reason I think
that if we have state funding going to
schools or any organization that we
should make sure that those
organizations do not discriminate
against people and that would be whether
or not it's intentional or direct
discrimination or if it's
the resulting discrimination there are
situations and I'll get into it in my
testimony where discrimination happens
and we see it happening in other voucher
type programs around the country we know
it's coming if New Hampshire is going to
go down this road we should make sure
that we don't allow what's happened
elsewhere to happen here because there
is significant discrimination in
particular against children with
disabilities and children of color that
may not be intended thinking back to the
last two hours where we talked about
higher education three things came
through to me quite clearly first was
that Clarity of legislation is better
second is that once you get into the
public forum then you want to make sure
that there's no discrimination that was
the the question why is this happening
there's the proposed previous law for
public universities and not private
universities and then the very
compelling testimony from the two
students at UNH School of Law one of
them said we wanted to have a healthy
balance of perspectives on campus and
again those principles will underscore
why I think this is this is a positive
bill so first I'd like to go into three
categories one is children with
disabilities we know that there is huge
differences between children who
participate in the education Freedom
accounts and in the public schools when
it comes to disabilities 18 of the
students in the public schools
our children with disabilities only six
percent in the efa's are children with
disabilities that's a 300 difference
that's because the public schools take
every child that comes to the school and
has to provide them with a free and
appropriate education those children
also have the right the whole slew of
procedural rights that go with that
in the private schools they don't have
to take any child they don't want to so
if they say this child is too expensive
if the service is required are too much
for us they won't take them or they will
just eventually suspend the student and
have them leave
and it is very clear that this program
functions essentially as a voucher if
you go look at the website where the
expenses are broken down over 60 some
odd percent are just direct payments for
tuition
the next most common thing it's kind of
hard because it's not really very
coherent bookkeeping that you can see if
you're a member of the public but the
next most common thing is Amazon item
required by School item required by
School and just keeps listing them all
so I think the huge vast majority of the
money is either for tuition or for a
book or a laptop required by School
which is the way that an old-fashioned
voucher would have worked when these uh
this first came along 20 years ago you
would get a voucher go to a school a
private school and that would cover your
tuition and your books so the important
thing here is that when you go to a
private school you have to give up your
right to a free and appropriate
education you give up at the door you
get your five thousand dollar check but
you give up your rights you don't have
them when you go into a private school
the council for exceptional children in
2020 issued their position statement on
public education dollars to fund School
vouchers and other voucher type programs
and they they're opposed to these for
four reasons first it excludes children
of low incomes and they talk about how
how what happens with the private
schools they if they're going to provide
additional Services they end up billing
the parents and here's what they say
this reality ultimately can make
vouchers and voucher type programs
appealing to Middle income and upper
middle income families but effectively
eliminates lower income families school
districts also report students with
disabilities leaving voucher-funded
schools because the student required
more services than the school could
provide
this that's discrimination we know
that's going to happen we need to make
sure that it doesn't happen the way to
make sure it happens is very simple put
into the rule for the efas that you
there will be no discrimination based on
disability if a private school wants to
participate in the program then they
must provide
full services to children with
disabilities otherwise low-income
students will not be able to participate
and that's discriminatory a second way
that it discriminates against children
with disabilities is that people have to
Forfeit their rights under the idea
which I just mentioned and it's right on
the website for the efas they say in
this report the guarantee of procedural
protections for parents and families is
a fundamental part of the idea and
without these Protections in private
schools families are left as unequal
Partners so that's the second reason why
the vouchers the efas should be required
to have full rights for students with
disabilities because they lose all of
those procedural protections and that
answers the question that I think it was
representative cordelli asks what's the
difference between the what happens with
uh the student who gets goes to an
out-of-state School actually they end up
going to Perkins School for the children
of the blind if you do that with a
public school placement you still have
your procedural Protections in place
when you go to the private school you
have zero procedural Protections in
place the third reason that they're
opposed to this is because children with
disabilities get pushed out they say
private schools are under no obligation
to keep a child enrolled during the
school year or offer re-enrollment in a
subsequent year evidence indicates that
private schools typically do not
re-enroll but push out children with a
history of discipline problems or
atypical behaviors that can diversely
affect other students so the students
with disabilities either don't get in
the door they are totally part way
through the season or they don't get to
come back the next year it's
discriminatory in effect even if the
efas want to treat everybody equally the
effect is that children with
disabilities are discriminated against
and the last reason they just they are
against it is because of the no less
restrictive environment cause private
schools are not subject to the lre the
least restrictive environment
requirements and there is the potential
for in-school segregation of children
and youth with disabilities so even if a
child with disabilities goes to a
private school they'll be segregated why
because they are not given the re the
protection for the least restrictive
environment which does carry with you in
the public school so the result is that
children with disabilities get
discriminated against in the voucher
plans you know this is going to happen
evidence around the country where this
has been done for 20 to 25 years tells
you that the way to make sure it doesn't
happen is to write it into the law that
it won't happen the other problem is
that the parents don't even know what
they're getting into in a previous Bill
a couple weeks ago I sent you a rather
long written testimony but I mentioned a
GAO report about private school choice
and vouchers and they talked about how
parents can't get information from these
private schools they don't know whether
or not they offer services specific to
their child is there somebody there
who's actually qualified to teach what
they study what the private school may
just have one person who deals with 10
students with disabilities and does
their best that they can for all of them
there's no legal protection in the
public school that child has a right to
an individual actual education program
and we'll be getting services from
people who are qualified and trained in
their specific area our governor who
obviously helped write this plan he
passed the legislation and all that you
will remember last September they had a
forum on disabilities in education
during the campaign and it was uh
Senator Sherman and governor sununu and
Governor sununo said when you go to a
private school through the voucher plan
you give up no legal rights and he
immediately was told that was incorrect
by online in the next day in the Press
by the rights Community he then came
back and said okay well all right you
get some rights that's all you get in
the private school is some rights you
give up your legal right to a free and
appropriate education when you leave
that public school so the way to make
sure this doesn't happen under a voucher
system if New Hampshire is going to
adhere to our philosophy of not
discriminating is to make it very clear
you asked earlier a question well it's
already in the civil rights law I
remember it was 393 or okay but
obviously that's in law we've seen this
program in effect for two years in
children with disabilities are not
getting legal rights they don't have due
process rights they don't have the least
restrictive environment right they have
no legal rights when they participate in
the voucher program if they go to a
private school that's why it needs to be
written into this law so that it's very
very clear that the intent of the
legislature is that that provision
follows over we had a judge testifying
earlier make your laws clear this would
make it very clear that that's what you
want the second group of people that
this is relevant to is Children of color
Indiana adopted a choice program and in
their program when the original uh
program went into effect the ratio of
white children to black children was two
to one there was two white children for
every one black child who signed up for
the voucher programs but
I'll just read it'd be much more simple
for you if I say research and practice
indicates that vouchers and voucher type
programs point us in the other direction
that's away from diverse student
populations these programs can
facilitate racial ethnic economic
religious gender and disability
segregation in Indiana the Indiana
school choice program which began in
2011 was built as a way to help poor
minority children Escape bad Public
Schools since then the percentage of
white voucher recipients has increased
from 46 to 60 percent and the percentage
of black recipients has dropped from 24
to 12 percent what does that mean in
year one the ratio is two to one two
white students for every black student
it is now five to one the black students
they're not working out it says in
practice they're not being able to
maintain in the voucher private schools
the white students are going there and
Deborah Howell also testified to this
too earlier you started two to one and
after a few years you find yourself at
five to one that tells you that in
practice there's discrete Nation I'm not
saying anybody's intending to
discriminate but if you know that that's
going to be the result if New Hampshire
is going to continue with efas we see
this coming from 20 years of research we
should put it into the law that says
race take it out of that other law
that's the generic law and put it right
into the EFA law along with disability
rights so that we make sure that when
people participate in the EFA if they
have a child who has a disability
they'll know that they keep their rights
the parent will never be confused as to
whether or not the rights follow them
and if you have if you're a parent with
a child of color you will know that your
child will not be unfairly suspended or
kicked out of the school or not re asked
to recumbact the next year put it in the
law it makes it clear the last group is
lgbtq students we know that lgbtq folks
make up about five percent of the New
Hampshire adult population and they make
up 22 percent of high school students in
this country that's from the latest
study done by the CDC
if we're going to have students who are
lgbtq going to private schools they will
want to be treated fairly now the
testimony earlier from the students at
the law school was so compelling they
just wanted to be treated like they were
welcomed in their school if imagine
being a student who comes out during
your high school years and you find
yourself in a voucher program and you're
in a private private school in which
bans members of the LGBT community from
teaching at that school there is nobody
there that you can look to as a mentor
no role model nobody who could be like
you they're going to be feeling the same
awful feelings that the previous
testimony came about if we're going to
have a society where we say when it's a
public forum when there's State actors
involved we want to make sure that
people who have religious beliefs feel
welcome like at the UNA School of Law
then if it's state money that's funding
these private schools then we want to
make sure that those protections also go
with the state money so that members of
the lgbtq community are not faced with
ridicule or feel like I can't stay with
this school because there's nobody here
who understands me so again Clarity in
the law will make sure that when we have
public actors we should have
uh civil rights following with the
financial aid coming from the state
thank you very much for listening thank
you very much are there questions from
the committee
thank you very much thank you Mr
chairman and with that we're going to
close down this hearing
and the week and adjourn
I mean we don't have the schedule will
be put out uh next week in the next
because what we have left that we just
have exact bills left approximately half
the bills we receive we still have to
exec and we'll start doing that on
Monday and rest assured we'll probably
start around 9 30 but there will be